Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca.
大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表Wayfair。有没有过在网上订购家具却担心“万一”的情况？比如，万一质量不好怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你本该从Wayfair订购的。在Wayfair，没有“万一”。只有你钟爱的风格和值得信赖的品质。请访问Wayfair.ca。
Wayfair, every style, every home. This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's, which has been backing British ambition for over 250 years. Now, when you think about it, every dynasty in history has boiled down. to two important elements. Aspiration and action. And a classic example of this from British history,
Wayfair，各种风格，各种家。本期节目由劳合社赞助，该机构已为英国的雄心壮志提供了250多年的支持。现在，当你仔细想想，历史上的每一个王朝都归结为两个重要要素：抱负与行动。英国历史上一个经典的例子，
the rise of the House of Wessex, the family of Alfred the Great and his heirs, who between them established the United Kingdom of England. Yeah, it's a great story, isn't it, Tom? A great lesson in leadership, I think, for anybody. So Alfred and his heirs, they marry idealism and pragmatism. they're brilliant at alliances, they're brilliant at managing power, their brilliance, of course, at managing their money, which is a key part of political leadership.
威塞克斯王朝的崛起，阿尔弗雷德大帝及其继承人的家族，他们共同建立了英格兰联合王国。是的，这是一个伟大的故事，不是吗，汤姆？我认为这对任何人来说都是一个伟大的领导力课程。所以阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人，他们将理想主义与实用主义结合在一起。他们擅长结盟，擅长管理权力，当然，他们也擅长管理金钱，这是政治领导力的关键部分。
And of course, we are all reaping the rewards of their wisdom and foresight. When it's time to make your next move, you can bank on Lloyd's to be ready when you are. Because from new businesses to new homes and new life chapters, backed by generations of hope and ambition, you can see, Tom, why 14 million people trust. Lloyd's to help make their dreams a reality. Based on Lloyd's internal customer data from March 2026. At the first grave dawn, it was a heavy heart. I got into the motor car and drove out to the prison. I sent in my name to Miss Cavill. If I remember rightly, the soldier told me she
当然，我们都在享受他们智慧和远见的成果。当你要采取下一步行动时，你可以信赖劳合社，他们随时准备为你提供支持。因为从新企业到新家，再到人生的新篇章，在几代人的希望和抱负的支持下，你可以看出，汤姆，为什么1400万人信任劳合社来帮助他们实现梦想。基于劳合社2026年3月的内部客户数据。在第一个灰暗的黎明，心情沉重。我坐进汽车，开车前往监狱。我让人把我的名字传给卡维尔小姐。如果我没记错的话，士兵告诉我她
had just been kneeling at her table. In the cell, a flickering gas flame was burning. Two large bouquets or visit flowers, which had been standing there for ten weeks, awakened the impression of a vault. The condemned lady had packed all her little property, his greatest care in a handbag. I accompanied her through the long corridors of the great prison. The Belgian prison official stood there and greeted her silently with the highest respect. She returned their greeting silently. And we boarded the motor car which awaited us in the yard, and I sat beside Edith Carval in order to accompany her to her own burial.
刚才一直跪在桌边。牢房里，一盏闪烁的煤气灯在燃烧。两束巨大的探视花束，已经在那里放了十周，让人感觉像个墓穴。这位被判刑的女士把她所有的小财产，她最珍视的东西都装进了一个手提包。我陪她走过大监狱的长廊。比利时监狱官员站在那里，默默地以最高的敬意向她致意。她也默默地回礼。我们登上了在院子里等候我们的汽车，我坐在伊迪丝·卡维尔身边，陪她去往她自己的葬礼。
So that was the German pastor Paul Lassour, who was chaplain at the great prison of Saint-Gilles in Brussels, and in that passage he is recalling the last hour. of a British nurse called Edith Carville, who was about to be executed by a German firing squad for war treason on the 12th of October 1915. And if you're wondering how a British nurse can be executed by the Germans for treason, well, we will be coming to that. And Dominic, you think that her life and death is one of the most moving stories of the entire First World War. and you were just saying how you wish that you had had the chance to talk about it with her. She would be high on your list of dinner party guests because it is an amazing story, isn't it? It's a story of spying and resistance and of courage and treachery and of patriotism and faith.
那是德国牧师保罗·拉苏尔，他是布鲁塞尔圣吉尔大监狱的随军牧师，在那段文字中，他回忆了英国护士伊迪丝·卡维尔的最后时刻，她即将于1915年10月12日因战争叛国罪被德国行刑队处决。如果你想知道一位英国护士怎么会被德国人以叛国罪处决，嗯，我们稍后会讲到。多米尼克，你认为她的一生和死亡是整个第一次世界大战中最感人的故事之一。你刚才说你多么希望有机会和她谈谈。她会是你晚宴宾客名单上的首选，因为这是一个了不起的故事，不是吗？这是一个关于间谍活动、抵抗、勇气、背叛、爱国主义和信仰的故事。
And she's such a fascinating character that it would make a really brilliant film, you'd said. That's not right, Tom. No, I was actually saying something very different about, I think I like a funster at a a dinner party. And I don't think Edith Cavill was, I don't think she was one of life's funsters. But a remarkable person. She was a remarkable person and it is a truly remarkable story that we'll be
你说她是一个如此迷人的人物，拍成电影一定会非常精彩。不对，汤姆。不，我其实说的是完全不同的事情，我想我喜欢晚宴上的开心果。我不认为伊迪丝·卡维尔是那种生活中的开心果。但她是一个非凡的人。她确实是一个非凡的人，这是一个真正非凡的故事，我们今天将
talking about today. So as you say, it's one of the most colourful and controversial stories of the whole First World War. And you say here that she's probably the war's single, best and casualty after Franz Ferdinand. Well, if you think about people who were killed in the First World War, especially people who were killed while not fighting.
讨论这个话题。正如你所说，这是整个第一次世界大战中最丰富多彩且最具争议的故事之一。你说她是继弗朗茨·斐迪南之后，战争中可能最著名的单一受害者。嗯，如果你想到第一次世界大战中丧生的人，尤其是那些在非战斗状态下丧生的人。
Which is true, both of Franz Ferdinand and of Edith Cavill. There aren't that many who have statues. Edith Kevel does, of course, have a statue. She has a statue of Trafalgar Square, and every day, I guess, every year, hundreds of thousands of people must walk past that statue. They probably barely give it a second's thought. Or they walk past the statue of her in King's Domain in Melbourne, in Australia. Or they walk along one of the countless Ru Edith Cavill in France or in Belgium. Or the schools and hospitals that are named after her, you know, all over the world in Australia, New Zealand, in Canada, in the United States,
这对于弗朗茨·斐迪南和伊迪丝·卡维尔来说都是事实。没有多少人拥有雕像。当然，伊迪丝·卡维尔确实有一座雕像。她在特拉法加广场有一座雕像，我想每天，或者每年，成千上万的人一定会经过那座雕像。他们可能几乎不会多看一眼。或者他们经过墨尔本国王公园里她的雕像。或者他们走在法国或比利时无数条以伊迪丝·卡维尔命名的街道上。或者以她命名的学校和医院，你知道，遍布世界各地，在澳大利亚、新西兰、加拿大、美国，
and here in Britain. And there was a monument to her in Paris, which no longer stands for reasons that we will be coming to in due course. Yes. So she became, I think, the great martyr of the First World War. Perhaps she's not as well known now as she used to be. But the story behind her martyrdom is an interesting one because it's a story, as we said, of espionage and secret machinations.
以及这里在英国。巴黎曾经有一座纪念她的纪念碑，但由于我们稍后会提到的原因，它已经不存在了。是的。所以我想，她成为了第一次世界大战的伟大殉道者。也许她现在不像过去那么出名了。但她殉道背后的故事很有趣，因为正如我们所说，这是一个关于间谍活动和秘密阴谋的故事。
And it's a complicated story, and let's get into it. We'll start with the place where it all happens, and that is plucky little Belgium. So people who listened to our first series about the Great War may recall that at the beginning of the war, Belgium resisted the German demands for free passage in August 1914,
这是一个复杂的故事，让我们深入了解一下。我们从这一切发生的地方开始，那就是勇敢的小比利时。所以听过我们关于大战的第一系列节目的听众可能还记得，在战争初期，比利时在1914年8月抵制了德国关于自由通行的要求，
but within weeks, Belgium was absolutely steam-rollered. These extraordinary scenes of the kind of grey ranks, like a tide, like a kind of tide of teutonic, militarism pouring through the streets of Brussels. You really just say that. A tide of Teutonic militarism. I did, but you know me, Tom. I do.
但在几周内，比利时就被彻底碾压了。这些非凡的场景，那种灰色的行列，像潮水一样，像一种条顿军国主义的潮水涌过布鲁塞尔的街道。你真的就这么说。条顿军国主义的潮水。我确实说了，但你了解我，汤姆。我确实说了。
I said it in a proving way. A tidal wave of Teutonic militarism. I love a tidal wave of Teutonic. I love a peaked helmet. So the Germans occupied Belgium. They executed infamously about 6,500 civilians in their reprisals against suspected partisans. And they burned the medieval core of the city of Lévin,
我是以一种赞同的方式说的。条顿军国主义的浪潮。我喜欢条顿人的浪潮。我喜欢尖顶头盔。所以德国人占领了比利时。他们臭名昭著地处决了大约6500名平民，作为对涉嫌游击队活动的报复。他们烧毁了鲁汶市的中世纪核心区，
Library, which I know you were very shocked by, as somebody who loves libraries. So, even before today's story begins, people in Britain and in neutral countries and the United States and so on, are primed to see Belgium as a place where teutonic barbarians in these kind of spiked helmets are carrying out dreadful atrocities against innocent women. So already there are British posters that sort of say, remember Belgium. and the image of Belgium as a sort of maiden being violated by slavering Huns. Yeah, it's kind of a gorilla, isn't it, with a club holding a, like, almost like King Kong. Completely, yeah.
图书馆，我知道你对此感到非常震惊，作为一个热爱图书馆的人。所以，甚至在今天的故事开始之前，英国、中立国和美国等地的人们就已经被引导，将比利时视为一个戴着尖顶头盔的条顿野蛮人对无辜妇女实施可怕暴行的地方。所以已经有英国海报说，记住比利时。以及比利时被描绘成一个被贪婪的匈奴人蹂躏的少女形象。是的，有点像大猩猩，不是吗，拿着棍子，几乎就像金刚一样。完全是，是的。
Holding a maiden in its arms. Yeah, exactly. So by the end of 1914, almost all of Belgium is under military occupation. It's been divided into three occupation zones, and the largest of these, which includes Brussels, is called the general government, anticipating what's, of course, going to happen to Poland in the Second World War. and here you have a German general and he leads a German-dominated administration. And it's actually a pretty heavy-handed occupation. So Belgium had been the world's sixth biggest economy before the war.
怀里抱着一个少女。是的，完全正确。所以到1914年底，几乎整个比利时都处于军事占领之下。它被划分为三个占领区，其中最大的一区，包括布鲁塞尔，被称为总督府，这预示着二战中波兰将会发生什么。在这里，你有一位德国将军，他领导着一个以德国人为主的行政机构。这实际上是一次相当高压的占领。所以比利时在战前曾是世界第六大经济体。
So much for plucky little Belgium. But the Germans dismantle the Belgian economy. They basically move loads of machinery and equipment to Germany and they deport more than 100,000 Belgian workers to German war factories. They even demand that the Belgians shift their time zone. so by an hour from GMT to Central European time. And for ordinary Belgians, these are grim years, the years of occupation. It's maybe not like being occupied by Nazi Germany, but there's a sense of national humiliation,
勇敢的小比利时也就这样了。但德国人拆解了比利时的经济。他们基本上把大量的机械和设备搬到了德国，并将超过10万名比利时工人驱逐到德国的战争工厂。他们甚至要求比利时人改变时区，从格林威治标准时间改为中欧时间。对于普通比利时人来说，这些是严酷的岁月，占领的岁月。这可能不像被纳粹德国占领那样，但有一种民族屈辱感，
there's an economic collapse, there are massive food shortages. One way that Belgians deal with this, I mean, Belgium is a very Catholic country, it's how they define themselves against their neighbours in the Netherlands. And there's a sort of revival of Catholicism, which actually, plays a part in today's story. And the other way they respond, of course, is by resistance. And we should be coming to this exactly how the Belgians resist. But resistance is where today's heroine, Edith Cavill, comes in.
经济崩溃，食物极度短缺。比利时人应对这种情况的一种方式，我的意思是，比利时是一个非常天主教的国家，这是他们定义自己与邻国荷兰不同的方式。而且有一种天主教的复兴，这实际上在今天的故事中起了一定作用。他们回应的另一种方式，当然是抵抗。我们应该会讲到比利时人究竟是如何抵抗的。但抵抗正是今天的主人公伊迪丝·卡维尔登场的地方。
And she, I have to say, is a very, very unlikely Belgian resistance hero. So she's a Victorian, born in 1865, in a village outside Norwich called Swadeston. And her father was the vicar there. He was called Frederick Cavill. He was the vicar there for almost half a century. He was like Nelson's dad. Yes, except he's more formidable. Nelson's dad was a little bit, was mild-mannered and easygoing. A bit wet, wasn't he?
而且我必须说，她是一个非常、非常不可能的比利时抵抗英雄。她是一位维多利亚时代的人，出生于1865年，在诺里奇郊外一个叫斯瓦德斯顿的村庄。她的父亲是那里的牧师。他叫弗雷德里克·卡维尔。他在那里做了近半个世纪的牧师。他就像纳尔逊的父亲。是的，除了他更令人生畏。纳尔逊的父亲有点，温和随和。有点软弱，不是吗？
This bloke's not wet at all. He's sort of terrifying Victorian with massive sideburns. I mean, an indication of what kind of man her father is. When his father was training to become a parson, he fell in love with his housekeeper's daughter, who was called Louise and he wanted to marry her. But he said to her, I will only marry you when you've educated yourself to an appropriate level for a Parsons wife.
这家伙一点也不软弱。他是一个可怕的维多利亚时代的人，留着巨大的鬓角。我的意思是，她父亲是什么样的人的一个迹象。当他的父亲在接受牧师培训时，他爱上了管家的女儿，名叫路易丝，他想娶她。但他对她说，我只有在你受过教育，达到适合牧师妻子的水平时，才会娶你。
And depending, you know, some people may say, that's unromantic of him. Others may applaud his high standards. I'll leave that to the listeners to decide. But anyway, this bloke gets a living in Norfolk, and that's where Edith is born, where she grows up. It's obviously a austere kind of existence. So they had servants, and one anecdote we have about the servants,
根据，你知道，有些人可能会说，这对他来说很不浪漫。其他人可能会赞赏他的高标准。我把这个留给听众去决定。但无论如何，这家伙在诺福克谋得了一个职位，那就是伊迪丝出生和成长的地方。这显然是一种简朴的生活。所以他们有仆人，关于仆人我们有一个轶事，
that a maid once scrawled in pencil on the wall of her attic bedroom. The pay is small, the food is bad, I wonder why I don't go mad. Which doesn't say much. For the jollity and generosity of the Caval family. Basically, we don't really know anything about Edith when she's growing up. I mean, the accounts that you find, she liked dogs, she liked ice skating, she liked flowers. But this is so generic. This is so sort of generic, saintly Victorian child that I don't think you can,
一个女仆曾经在阁楼卧室的墙上用铅笔潦草地写道：工资很少，食物很差，我不知道为什么我没有发疯。这并没有说明卡维尔家族的快乐和慷慨。基本上，我们对伊迪丝成长过程中的情况一无所知。我的意思是，你找到的记录说，她喜欢狗，喜欢滑冰，喜欢花。但这太普通了。这是一种非常普通的、圣洁的维多利亚时代的孩子，我不认为你可以，
extrapolate much from it. She's educated at home at first and she goes to a series of boarding schools. Her big thing at boarding school apparently was French. She has a great gift for French. And at her school in Peterborough, they do no fewer than 10 whole minutes of French conversation every day. Unbelievable. I mean, people say that the British don't bother learning foreign languages. Total fluency. Yeah. She's tremendous linguist. She's not learning Flemish, though. This is not exactly, no. So she works as a governess. And then in 1890, she is recommended for a post in Brussels, where she goes off to work for the Francois family. And what is she like?
从中推断出什么。她起初在家里接受教育，然后去了一系列寄宿学校。她在寄宿学校最擅长的是法语。她有极高的法语天赋。在彼得伯勒的学校里，他们每天进行不少于10分钟的完整法语对话。难以置信。我的意思是，人们说英国人不屑于学习外语。完全流利。是的。她是一位了不起的语言学家。不过她没学弗拉芒语。这不完全是，不。所以她做家庭教师。然后在1890年，她被推荐到布鲁塞尔的一个职位，她去那里为弗朗索瓦一家工作。她是什么样的人？
Now, you said at the beginning that she might be a fun person to talk to at a dinner party. I'm not so sure. So the accounts that you have of her as a young woman, she's very short. I mean, that's not a reason not to talk to her at a dinner party. But she's not a one of life's funsters and japsters. So a trainee nurse who's met her later said, her voice was low agreeable and cultured, her French fluent, which she's done 10 minutes a day.
现在，你在开头说她可能是一个在晚宴上聊天很有趣的人。我不太确定。所以你作为年轻女性对她的描述，她非常矮。我的意思是，那不是不在晚宴上和她交谈的理由。但她不是那种生活中的开心果和爱开玩笑的人。所以后来见过她的一位实习护士说，她的声音低沉、悦耳且有教养，法语流利，这是她每天10分钟练习的结果。
everything around her, the neatness of her attire, her attitude and poise, the words she used, all conveyed her characteristic efficiency, thoroughness, serenity and kindness. They're not attributes that I look for in a conversation list, frankly, but anyway. Anglicanism at its best. Obviously, she has this very, very sort of Christian sensibility. She wrote to her cousin, "'Someday I'm going to do something useful, something for people. They're most of them so helpless, so hurt and so unhappy.'"
她周围的一切，她着装的整洁，她的态度和风度，她使用的词汇，都传达了她特有的效率、彻底、宁静和善良。坦率地说，这些不是我在谈话对象中寻找的特质，但无论如何。圣公会的最佳典范。显然，她有这种非常、非常基督教的感性。她写信给她的表弟：“总有一天我要做些有用的事，为人们做些事。他们大多数人如此无助，如此受伤，如此不快乐。”
I mean, you bring her alive, you bring her alive. and I frankly, however short she is, I would relish the chance to spend an evening, listening to her talk about flower arranging. I think there's just a trace in her conversation of the Grantham grocer shop, no? Of the Grantham Grammar School Girl who's going to lecture you about God's plans for you. Anyway, in the 1890, she comes home from Brussels, and she ends up training as a nurse, and she rises to become the assistant matron of a hospital in Shortwich. Now, on the issue of her as a dinner party companion, I mean, I didn't think this would be such a theme of the episode, but there we are. She's very good at running this hospital, but she's not a bundle of laughs. So these are the reports of her from the late 1890s and 1900s. A very strict person who demands obedience from others. Orderly, methodical and of kindly and gentle disposition. Unbelievably, unselfish with an almost fanatical sense of duty, rather withdraw.
我的意思是，你让她活灵活现，你让她活灵活现。坦率地说，无论她有多矮，我都会很乐意花一个晚上听她谈论插花。我认为她的谈话中有一丝格兰瑟姆杂货店的味道，不是吗？那个格兰瑟姆文法学校的女孩要给你讲上帝对你的计划。无论如何，在1890年，她从布鲁塞尔回家，最终在肖特威奇的一家医院接受护士培训，并升任助理护士长。现在，关于她作为晚宴同伴的问题，我的意思是，我没想到这会成为这一集的主题，但事实就是这样。她非常擅长管理这家医院，但她不是一个充满欢笑的人。所以这些是19世纪90年代末和1900年代关于她的报告。一个非常严格的人，要求别人服从。有序、有条理，性格善良温和。难以置信地无私，有一种近乎狂热的责任感，相当内向。
drawn, uninterested in superficial friendships, but thoughtful, pleasant and sympathetic to all her patients. Does that tick your boxes, Tom? Yeah. But anyway, in 1907, she is recruited to go back to Belgium. Now, she'd been working as a governess for the Francois family. And they have a family friend with Dr. Antoine de Pages. How familiar are you, Tom, with the history of Belgian nursing?
退缩，对肤浅的友谊不感兴趣，但对所有病人都是体贴、愉快和富有同情心的。这符合你的要求吗，汤姆？是的。但无论如何，在1907年，她被招募回比利时。现在，她曾为弗朗索瓦一家做家庭教师。他们有一位家庭朋友，安托万·德·佩奇医生。汤姆，你对比利时护理的历史有多熟悉？
Pretty familiar. I mean, everyone obviously has heard of Dr. Antoine de Page. He's a name that trips off the tongue when discussing the history of Belgian. nursing. I mean, if you want to go deeper into the weeds, then maybe not. But Dr. Antoine de Paj, I know all about him. Doing a bonus, surely. Well, Dr. Antoine de Page. He's the Belgian royal surgeon, isn't he? And he's also, he's founder of the Belgian Red Cross. And also, he was co-founder of the Belgian Boy Scouts. And Dominic, here's an amazing fact about him, which, of course, you will know, but probably listeners who,
相当熟悉。我的意思是，每个人显然都听说过安托万·德·佩奇医生。在讨论比利时护理历史时，他的名字脱口而出。我的意思是，如果你想深入研究，那可能不是。但安托万·德·佩奇医生，我对他了如指掌。肯定有加分项。嗯，安托万·德·佩奇医生。他是比利时皇家外科医生，不是吗？他也是比利时红十字会的创始人。而且，他还是比利时童子军的联合创始人。多米尼克，关于他有一个惊人的事实，当然你会知道，但可能听众，
know the outline of his life may not be aware of this. His daughter Marie died on the Lusitania. Probably everyone does know that, but just for the few who don't know anything about him, it's an interesting fact. And also, isn't it the case that he's very keen to set up Belgian's first nursing school on the outskirts of Brussels? Because up until this point, nursing has been largely controlled by Catholic nuns. Yeah.
了解他生平大纲的人可能不知道这一点。他的女儿玛丽死在卢西塔尼亚号上。可能每个人都知道这一点，但对于那些对他一无所知的人来说，这是一个有趣的事实。而且，他非常热衷于在布鲁塞尔郊外建立比利时第一所护士学校，不是吗？因为直到那时，护理工作在很大程度上一直由天主教修女控制。是的。
Dr. Antoine Departre thinks that nuns are backward and useless. and so he wants to bring Edith Carville in as a matron and director. So, Dominic, what about Edith? How does she come in? Dr. DePaschester, come and set up this nursing school. She says, brilliant. Can't wait. She goes over to Belgium.
安托万·德·佩奇医生认为修女们落后且无用。所以他想请伊迪丝·卡维尔担任护士长和院长。那么，多米尼克，伊迪丝呢？她是怎么加入的？德·佩奇医生说，来建立这所护士学校吧。她说，太棒了。等不及了。她去了比利时。
She goes to Brussels. She sets up Belgium's first ever professional nursing journal. Did you know that? And she's so interesting, Dominic, isn't she, that she gets the second job as matron of the big new secular hospital at Saint-Sangeel. It's mad that some people say she's not interesting. It doesn't get more interesting than that. And then in 1914, she goes,
她去了布鲁塞尔。她创办了比利时有史以来第一本专业护理杂志。你知道吗？而且她太有趣了，多米尼克，不是吗，她还得到了圣吉尔大型新世俗医院护士长的第二份工作。有些人说她不有趣，这太疯狂了。没有比这更有趣的了。然后在1914年，她去了，
back in the summer, doesn't she, to Norfolk, to visit her elderly mother who's now widow? So that's sad. The father's dead. She goes back to Norfolk. Alan Partridge's heartland. And the story goes that she is weeding her mother's garden in College Road Norwich when she hears the news of the German invasion of Belgium. So if there was a film, this is the point at which a small child kicking a ball says, Have you heard? Germany has invaded Belgium. She's like, what? And her mum says to her, don't go back. Edith and Edith, because she's a saint, says, My duty is with my nurses.
夏天回到了诺福克，去探望她年迈的母亲，她现在是寡妇了？所以这很悲伤。父亲去世了。她回到诺福克。艾伦·帕特里奇的心脏地带。故事是这样的，当她听到德国入侵比利时的消息时，她正在诺里奇学院路的母亲花园里除草。所以如果有一部电影，这就是一个小孩子踢球说，你听说了吗？德国入侵了比利时。她就像，什么？她妈妈对她说，别回去，伊迪丝。伊迪丝因为她是圣人，说，我的职责与我的护士们在一起。
At a time like this, I am more needed than ever. Now, as this might suggest, we are very dependent for all this on incredibly treakly hagiographies that were written after her death. So whether this really happened and whether she really said this, you know, Listers can draw their own conclusions. Anyway. But why otherwise would she have gone back? I mean, it seems plausible to me.
在这样的时刻，我比以往任何时候都更需要。现在，正如这可能暗示的那样，我们非常依赖她死后写的那些极其甜腻的圣徒传。所以这是否真的发生过，她是否真的说了这些话，你知道，听众可以得出自己的结论。无论如何。但如果不这样，她为什么要回去呢？我的意思是，这对我来说似乎是合理的。
Maybe she wants to set up another nursing journal in Belgium, might become the matron of a third hospital. I don't know. Not with a tidal wave of grey Prussian militarism descending on her. Right, a tidal wave of Teutonic militarism. Exactly. Anyway, by the 3rd of August, she's gone back to Brussels. She sends the German nurses that she's got home.
也许她想在比利时创办另一本护理杂志，可能会成为第三家医院的护士长。我不知道。但不是在灰色的普鲁士军国主义浪潮降临到她身上的时候。对，条顿军国主义的浪潮。完全正确。无论如何，到8月3日，她已经回到了布鲁塞尔。她把她手下的德国护士送回了家。
She says, you can go home. She says to the other nurses, your task is to care for any soldiers regardless of their nationality. Any wounded soldier must be treated, friend or foe. Every man is a father, husband or son. As nurses, you must take no part in the quarrel. Our work is for humanity. the profession of nursing
她说，你们可以回家了。她对其他护士说，你们的任务是照顾任何士兵，无论他们的国籍如何。任何受伤的士兵都必须得到治疗，无论是朋友还是敌人。每个人都是父亲、丈夫或儿子。作为护士，你们不得参与争吵。我们的工作是为了人类。护理专业
there's no frontiers so 20th of August she's been back for two weeks and Brussels falls and you know the German tidal wave tramps into the city and Edith writes in her journal
没有国界。所以8月20日，她回来两周了，布鲁塞尔沦陷了，你知道德国的浪潮践踏进了城市，伊迪丝在她的日记中写道
we were divided between pity for those poor fellows far from their country and their people so she's talking about the Germans there she's talking about the Germans suffering the weariness and fatigue of an arduous campaign this is my kind of talk
我们对那些远离家乡和亲人的可怜人感到怜悯，所以她在谈论那里的德国人，她在谈论德国人承受着艰苦战役的疲惫和劳累，这是我喜欢的话题
and hate of a vindictive foe bringing ruin and desolation on hundreds of happy homes and to a prosperous and peaceful land. Now, by this point, our training school and the sort of clinic have been converted into a Red Cross hospital and all English nurses have now been sent home. But Edith stays on with her assistant who's called Miss Wilkins. And would I be correct in assuming that Miss Wilkins is English as well?
以及对一个报复性的敌人的仇恨，它给数百个幸福的家庭以及一个繁荣和平的土地带来了毁灭和荒凉。现在，到这个时候，我们的培训学校和诊所已经被改造成了红十字医院，所有的英国护士现在都被送回家了。但伊迪丝和她的助手威尔金斯小姐留了下来。我假设威尔金斯小姐也是英国人，对吗？
Exactly, she is. I imagine her as having steel-rimmed spectacles. Prost-nay. So then a few weeks later comes to the moment that changes her life. Yeah, of course. This is where Dr. DePage comes back. So he's the guy who first brought her to Belgium. Yes.
完全正确，她是。我想象她戴着钢框眼镜。鼻夹眼镜。所以几周后，改变她一生的时刻到来了。是的，当然。这就是德·佩奇医生回来的地方。所以他是第一个把她带到比利时的人。是的。
And he has his daughter, Marie, doesn't he? Remember what happens to Marie? What happens to Marie? Oh, she ends up on the Lusitania. But before she gets on the Lusitania, she comes to see Edith and says that a friend has come to ask her for help with two British soldiers, Lieutenant Colonel Dudley Bodger and Sergeant Major Frank Meachin. I think it's Dudley Bogher. No? Oh, God, you know, all these years I've been reading about this and I thought it was Bodger.
他有他的女儿玛丽，不是吗？记得玛丽发生了什么吗？玛丽发生了什么？哦，她最终上了卢西塔尼亚号。但在她上卢西塔尼亚号之前，她来见伊迪丝，说一位朋友来请求她帮助两名英国士兵，达德利·博格中校和弗兰克·米钦军士长。我想是达德利·博格。不？哦，天哪，你知道，这些年来我一直在读关于这个的故事，我以为是博格。
So these two guys were both in the Cheshishers, and they both fought in the Battle of Mons. Remember the Angels and Mons, Tom, the archers who saved the British. So they were both badly wounded in the British retreat from Mons. They were captured and they were taken to a temporary German hospital in a nearby convent, German military hospital. Now, both of them incredibly managed to escape from the Germans in the night, and they hid in a village where Belgian families took them in, and now they need Edith's help, basically because they're still injured and they need to get out. of Belgium.
所以这两个家伙都在柴郡团，他们都在蒙斯战役中战斗过。记得蒙斯的天使，汤姆，拯救了英国人的弓箭手？所以他们在英国从蒙斯撤退时都受了重伤。他们被俘虏，被带到附近修道院的一个临时德国医院，德国军事医院。现在，他们两人在夜间不可思议地成功从德国人手中逃脱，他们躲在一个村庄里，比利时家庭收留了他们，现在他们需要伊迪丝的帮助，基本上是因为他们仍然受伤，需要离开比利时。
And she says, yes, she will help them. This is when Marie has come to ask her, will she do it in principle? And then on the evening of the 1st November 1914, a guide brings these two blokes to Edith's Clinic, which is at Rue du convent in Brussels. And Bogor, or Bodger, as you call him, is dressed as a factory worker,
她说，是的，她会帮助他们。这是玛丽来问她的时候，她原则上会做吗？然后在1914年11月1日晚上，一名向导把这两个家伙带到了伊迪丝的诊所，位于布鲁塞尔的修道院街。博格，或者你叫他博格，穿着工人的衣服，
and he's wearing what I read is a floppy Belgian black beret. So he looks very entertaining. and he's grown a beard to disguise himself. No Britain, no British soldier would ever have a beard at this point. And he's wounded, so he'd been hit in the hand and the thigh and the foot. So he needs medical help. And Meachin is dressed as a Belgian labourer, but he's also disguised himself as a hunchback.
他戴着我读到的一种松垮的比利时黑色贝雷帽。所以他看起来非常有趣。他留了胡子来伪装自己。没有英国人，没有英国士兵在这一点上会留胡子。他受伤了，所以他的手、大腿和脚都被击中了。所以他需要医疗救助。米钦穿着比利时工人的衣服，但他还把自己伪装成驼背。
He's wearing like a comedy hunch. That is always the mark of a bad actor, isn't it? Someone who just goes that little bit too far, puts on a limp, developed a hunchback. Yeah, eyepatch, surely. An eye patch. But the rationale for this is that, you know, he's a man of fighting age. So if the Germans say to him, why are you not in the army, he can gesture at his hunch.
他戴着像喜剧里的驼背。那总是坏演员的标志，不是吗？那种做得太过火的人，装瘸，弄个驼背。是的，眼罩，肯定。眼罩。但理由是，你知道，他是战斗年龄的男人。所以如果德国人问他，你为什么不在军队里，他可以指着他的驼背。
And that will be the reason. So Edith takes these two blokes in. She keeps them hidden in the clinic and she personally tends to their wounds. And then, after seven days, the Belgian guide returns to collect them. And they're going to be passed from one person to another to escort the towards the frontier with the neutral Netherlands, so Holland, from where they would be able to escape back to Britain. Now, Colonel Bojure or Bojure didn't make it.
那将是原因。所以伊迪丝收留了这两个家伙。她把他们藏在诊所里，亲自照顾他们的伤口。然后，七天后，比利时向导回来接他们。他们将被从一个人传给另一个人，护送他们前往中立的荷兰边境，从那里他们将能够逃回英国。现在，博格上校或者博格没有成功。
He could barely walk, unfortunately, because he'd been wounded in the thigh and the foot, and he was captured on the outskirts of Brussels when the Germans discovered that he was carrying a false passport. But this boat Meachin, previously disguised as a hunchback, has now disguised himself as a fish hawker. So a man who sells fish, fish, Fish.
他几乎走不动路，不幸的是，因为他的大腿和脚受了伤，当德国人发现他携带假护照时，他在布鲁塞尔郊外被捕了。但这个家伙米钦，之前伪装成驼背，现在伪装成鱼贩。所以一个卖鱼的人，鱼，鱼。
Poisson. Poisson. It's an easy part to play, no? I mean, yeah. And I suppose if you smell very violent, yeah, horrible. Very violently of fish. People won't approach you.
鱼。这是一个容易扮演的角色，不是吗？我的意思是，是的。而且我想如果你闻起来非常强烈，是的，可怕。非常强烈的鱼腥味。人们不会靠近你。
So he got to Holland, he went home, he came back to France, and he ended up winning a medal in 1917. So that was nice. So this is the beginning of Edith Cavill's connections with the Belgian resistance. Now, I mentioned, we mentioned the occupation.
所以他到了荷兰，他回了家，他回到了法国，最终在1917年赢得了一枚奖章。所以那很好。这就是伊迪丝·卡维尔与比利时抵抗运动联系的开始。现在，我提到了，我们提到了占领。
The Belgian resistance, is not one big organized group. I mean, this isn't the case with all resistance groups, really. It's basically about 300 different kind of interlocking groups that attract both men and women. They're very informal. You kind of come and go. And they do some sabotage acts,
比利时抵抗运动，不是一个大的有组织的团体。我的意思是，这并不是所有抵抗组织的情况，真的。它基本上是由大约300个不同的相互交织的团体组成的，吸引了男人和女人。他们非常非正式。你来来去去。他们做一些破坏行为，
but by and large, what the Belgian resistance largely do is they distribute underground newspapers and pamphlets, and they get intelligence on what the Germans are up to. So German troop movements, and they send it across the border to the Allies. And the other thing, of course, they do, which these two blokes have just been the benefit, fisheries of, they smuggle Allied soldiers to safety because there's a lot of Allied soldiers
但总的来说，比利时抵抗运动主要做的是分发地下报纸和传单，并获取德国人动向的情报。所以德国军队的调动，他们把情报传送到边境给盟军。另一件事，当然，他们做的是，这两个家伙刚刚受益的，他们走私盟军士兵到安全地带，因为有很多盟军士兵
that have been left behind enemy lines during the chaotic retreat at the end of 1914. And so through her friend Marie de Page, the daughter of Top Belgian Dr. Antoine de Page, Edith is now connected to one of these resistance groups. And this is a resistance group that has very aristocratic leanings because it is centered on Prince Reginal de Croix and his sister Princess Marie and the Cois, the House of Cois, a kind of Belgian aristocratic house, dates back I read to medieval Burgundy.
在1914年底混乱的撤退中被留在了敌后。所以通过她的朋友玛丽·德·佩奇，顶级比利时医生安托万·德·佩奇的女儿，伊迪丝现在与这些抵抗组织之一建立了联系。这是一个有非常贵族倾向的抵抗组织，因为它以雷吉纳尔·德·克鲁瓦亲王和他的妹妹玛丽·德·克鲁瓦公主为中心，克鲁瓦家族，一个比利时贵族家族，我读到可以追溯到中世纪的勃艮第。
Are they members of the Golden Fleece? I don't think they are. Okay, so they're not that posh. They're not that posh, but quite posh. And during the fighting at the Battle of Montes, the Croix family had used their chateau at Bellini, which is not that far from Mons. They turned it into a hospital.
他们是金羊毛骑士团的成员吗？我不认为他们是。好吧，所以他们没那么时髦。他们没那么时髦，但相当时髦。在蒙斯战役的战斗中，克鲁瓦家族使用了他们在贝利尼的城堡，离蒙斯不远。他们把它变成了一家医院。
for wounded Allied soldiers. And they're now using their chateau to hide allied soldiers and to send them on to neutral Holland. So the way it works is this. Basically, if you have a British and you've been hiding in someone's pig style or something because you were left behind during the retreat from malls, Belgians will take you to the chateau
为受伤的盟军士兵。他们现在利用他们的城堡来隐藏盟军士兵，并将他们送往中立的荷兰。所以它的运作方式是这样的。基本上，如果你是一个英国人，你一直躲在某人的猪圈里，因为你在从蒙斯撤退时被留下了，比利时人会把你带到城堡，
and introduce you to the prince and princess and they will give you forged papers. I mean, how they are forging these papers, I do not know. whether the Prince Reginald has kind of got a machine in his hand cranking a passport machine or something. Anyway, they'll give you your forged papers, and then they'll introduce you to a series of guides to take you to the Dutch frontier. And the bloke is in charge of organizing the guides is an architect and Catholic social activist called Philippe Bouque. And Boch is like a big resistance figure, because he also distributes 200 grand papers,
介绍你给亲王和公主，他们会给你伪造的文件。我的意思是，他们是如何伪造这些文件的，我不知道。雷吉纳尔亲王是否手里有一台机器在制造护照什么的。无论如何，他们会给你伪造的文件，然后他们会介绍你给一系列向导，带你前往荷兰边境。负责组织向导的家伙是一位建筑师和天主教社会活动家，名叫菲利普·博克。博克是一个大的抵抗人物，因为他还分发200份报纸，
La Libre Belgique and Le Maud du Solda. and there's about 200 people in this network. They say they have safe houses and there are people who are going to, you'll take you from here to here, then I'll pass you on to this person, all of this. And it's very informal.
《自由比利时报》和《士兵世界》。这个网络里大约有200人。他们说他们有安全屋，有人会带你从这里到这里，然后我会把你传给这个人，所有这些。而且非常非正式。
A lot of them are actually just rich, posh Belgians who've got big houses so they can hide you in, you know, in one of their many bedrooms or something. And there's a slight sense, I think, about this, of sort of rich people having fun,
他们中的许多人实际上只是富有、时髦的比利时人，他们有大房子，所以他们可以把你藏在，你知道，他们的许多卧室之一里。而且我认为，对此有一种轻微的感觉，即富人玩得开心，
having a little bit of an adventure. Sure, I shall smuggle some British and French soldiers to safety, all of this. But, I mean, you do risk being shot, don't you if you're found out by the Germans? It's sort of, on the one hand, you risk being shot. On the other hand, it's a bit of a lark. So their password, for example, is York, which is Y-O-R-C, which is quat backwards. Which doesn't seem to me like the, it's a bit enablighton in terms of passwords.
有一点冒险。当然，我应该走私一些英国和法国士兵到安全地带，所有这些。但是，我的意思是，如果你被德国人发现，你确实冒着被枪毙的风险，不是吗？一方面，你冒着被枪毙的风险。另一方面，这有点像恶作剧。所以他们的密码，例如，是York，即Y-O-R-C，是Croy倒过来拼。这对我来说看起来不像，这在密码方面有点像伊妮德·布莱顿。
I suppose it's the beginning of the war, so, you know. Yeah, they're having fun. So Edith's role in this is two-fold, I think. One, medical, so they bring soldiers to training school in Brussels. where she looks after them and two, the clinic itself becomes an important safe house so a link in the chain in the Belgian capital. Now there probably also is an espionage dimension to all this.
我想这是战争初期，所以，你知道。是的，他们玩得很开心。所以我认为伊迪丝在其中的角色是双重的。第一，医疗，所以他们把士兵带到布鲁塞尔的培训学校。她在那里照顾他们；第二，诊所本身成为了一个重要的安全屋，即比利时首都链条中的一环。现在，这一切可能还有一个间谍维度。
It's impossible to say with any certainty. She's a woman of mystery. Yeah, but probably some of the men who are coming through her clinic are carrying intelligence for the Allies. We don't know really how formalised this was or whether this is just very informal, but anyway. In total, between November,
无法确定地说。她是一个神秘的女人。是的，但可能一些通过她诊所的人正在为盟军携带情报。我们真的不知道这有多正式，或者这是否只是非常非正式，但无论如何。总共，在1914年11月，
1914, July 1915, Edith is thought to have helped about 60 British and 15 French soldiers. So these are people who've been left behind in the retreat. But she's also thought to have helped about 100 young Frenchmen or young Belgians who want to get to Holland because they want to join the war on the Allied side. So they can't go west, as it were. So they go the long way around by going east to Holland, then to Britain, then back to France, because they're desperate to fight. And to give you just one example of the people she saved,
1915年7月之间，伊迪丝被认为帮助了大约60名英国和15名法国士兵。所以这些人是在撤退中被留下的。但她也被认为帮助了大约100名想去荷兰的年轻法国人或年轻比利时人，因为他们想加入盟军一方参加战争。所以他们不能向西走，正如他们所说。所以他们绕远路，向东去荷兰，然后去英国，然后回到法国，因为他们渴望战斗。为了给你举一个她拯救的人的例子，
this is on, there's an Edith Cavill website, and this is where I discovered this story. I recommend it to people, just Google it. And this is a bloke called Billy Mapes, who was a private and came from a village outside Norwich. So Edith's, neck of the woods. Yeah, he is neck of the woods. He fought in the first battalion of the Norfolk Regiment.
这是在，有一个伊迪丝·卡维尔网站，我就是在那里发现这个故事的。我向人们推荐它，谷歌一下就行。这是一个叫比利·梅普斯的家伙，他是一名列兵，来自诺里奇郊外的一个村庄。所以是伊迪丝的，老家。是的，他是老家。他在诺福克团第一营战斗。
He was wounded in the British retreat. He was cut off, like these other blokes, captured by the Germans, taken to a Red Cross convent, escapes. He shelters in the home of the family called the Camus family, like the Le Tranger. No relation. At one point, the Germans actually searched the house of this family looking for British soldiers, but they didn't find him.
他在英国撤退中受伤。他像其他人一样被切断，被德国人俘虏，带到红十字修道院，逃脱了。他躲在一个叫卡缪的家庭的家里，像《局外人》一样。没有关系。有一次，德国人实际上搜查了这个家庭的房子寻找英国士兵，但他们没有找到他。
The family put him in touch with this prince and princess to Croix. They smuggled him to Brussels. He's still minging the ankle, but he makes his way to eat his clinic. She recognized his Norfolk accent straight away. So loads of Norfolk bantz, which was great. She knew his village. She'd been to his village, so that was lovely. She nursed him back to fitness,
这个家庭让他与德·克鲁瓦亲王和公主取得了联系。他们把他走私到布鲁塞尔。他仍然瘸着脚，但他设法去了伊迪丝的诊所。她立刻认出了他的诺福克口音。所以有很多诺福克的玩笑，这很棒。她认识他的村庄。她去过他的村庄，所以那很可爱。她护理他恢复健康，
and then she organised for him to escape to the Dutch border with six other men. Their first attempt to cross the border was a disaster. It turned out that the Germans had reinforced the border with electric wires and increased patrols. Now that tells you something that the Germans are kind of on to what's happening and we'll come back to this.
然后她组织他和另外六个人逃往荷兰边境。他们第一次越境尝试是一场灾难。事实证明，德国人已经用电线加强了边境并增加了巡逻。现在这告诉你一些事情，德国人有点意识到发生了什么，我们会回到这一点。
But they made a second successful attempt to escape, they got across, and they got back to England. This bloke mapes. he'd been listed by the army as missing presumed dead and his local vicar in his Norfolk village had offered to organise a memorial service for him and his mother had said no I won't give up hope and when he walked down the street into the village
但他们进行了第二次成功的逃跑尝试，他们越过了边境，回到了英国。这个家伙梅普斯。他被军队列为失踪推定死亡，他诺福克村里的牧师曾提出为他组织追悼会，他的母亲说不，我不会放弃希望。当他走在街上进入村庄时，
everybody started crying because they were so it was so moved to see him back from the dead and when he was interviewed later he had a Hollywood instinct this bloke because he said that before he left Edith Cattle made a point of kissing him on the cheek and saying to him her final words were, Dear old Norfolk, I'd do anything to help a Norfolk man.
每个人都开始哭泣，因为他们太感动了，看到他死而复生。当他后来接受采访时，这个家伙有一种好莱坞的直觉，因为他说在他离开之前，伊迪丝·卡维尔特意亲吻了他的脸颊，对他说，她最后的遗言是，亲爱的老诺福克，我愿意做任何事来帮助一个诺福克人。
Okay, and hold on. So he's reporting this in a local newspaper in Norfolk. Yeah, but years later. Oh, okay, so not at the time. Well, we should come to this because at the time, some of the people that escaped do give interviews to their local newspapers, although by and large they are quite circumspect about exactly how they got out. But we'll come back to this point because it's an important one.
好的，等等。所以他在诺福克的一份当地报纸上报道了这个。是的，但那是几年后。哦，好的，所以当时没有。嗯，我们应该谈谈这个，因为当时，一些逃脱的人确实接受了当地报纸的采访，尽管他们大体上对他们是如何逃出来的守口如瓶。但我们会回到这一点，因为这很重要。
So as early as the spring of 1915, so just within months of really starting this operation, things are starting to go wrong. And the process to qua is worried that the network has been compromised. Now, part of this is because, you mentioned giving interviews, part of this is because of this issue about people giving interviews when they get home to the kind of, you know, I don't know, the non-eaten bugle or something to say, I hid in somebody in a barrel in a belt, family's place. Then I went to a safe house. Then a kindly nurse helped me and then I got home. So the Germans can, you know, it's not like the Germans can't read. There are many English nurses working in Brussels. Some of the people actually write postcards to Edith, to thank her. So that by Billy Makes gave an interview to an East Anglia newspaper. He didn't mention her. He didn't mention the nursing school. But it was kind of obvious that somebody must have helped him.
所以早在1915年春天，也就是真正开始这次行动后的几个月内，事情就开始出错了。德·克鲁瓦家族担心网络已经泄露。现在，部分原因是，你提到了接受采访，部分原因是关于人们回家后接受采访的问题，你知道，我不知道，非伊顿号角之类的报纸，说，我躲在某人的桶里，在比利时家庭的地方。然后我去了安全屋。然后一位善良的护士帮助了我，然后我回家了。所以德国人可以，你知道，并不是德国人不会阅读。在布鲁塞尔有许多英国护士在工作。有些人实际上给伊迪丝写明信片感谢她。所以比利·梅普斯接受了一份东安格利亚报纸的采访。他没有提到她。他没有提到护士学校。但很明显，一定有人帮助了他。
And the prince, the prince de Croix, actually sent a message to the British and said, could you please stop this appearing in your newspapers because this is very dodgy for us if this keeps appearing. Sometime around May 1915, Princess Marie actually goes to Brussels to see Edith and to say, I'm worried that the Germans are going to find out. And Edith was very alarmed and said you shouldn't have come. Like, you know, this is too public. And the princess said, we should think about shutting the operation down.
德克鲁瓦亲王实际上给英国人发了条消息，说能不能请你们别再让这些报道出现在报纸上了，如果这种事一直出现，对我们来说非常棘手。1915年5月左右，玛丽公主亲自前往布鲁塞尔见伊迪丝，说她担心德国人会发现。伊迪丝非常惊慌，说你不该来的。你知道的，这太公开了。公主说，我们应该考虑停止这项行动。
But then she mentioned almost casually there are 30 more men in the Combray area. and either said, oh, we must save these men. If one of them were caught and shot, it would be our fault. And then one day, not long after that, a new fugitive arrives at her clinic. And his name is George Gaston-Cillon. And he says to her, I'm a French officer. When the French captured my hometown, which is at Saint-Contin, I went into hiding, and I need money and I need help to get to the Dutch border.
但随后她几乎随口提到，在贡布雷地区还有30名士兵。伊迪丝说，哦，我们必须救这些人。如果他们中有人被抓并被枪决，那将是我们的错。不久之后的一天，她的诊所来了一名新的逃亡者。他的名字叫乔治·加斯顿-西隆。他对她说，我是一名法国军官。当法国人占领我的家乡圣康坦时，我躲了起来，我需要钱，也需要帮助才能到达荷兰边境。
I needed this slightly puzzled by this story, because Kian, unlike most of the fugitives, says to her, can I have 300 francs? I need 300 francs. Now, it's not clear to her why he needs this, because if he is who he says he is, then when he gets to Holland, he can go to the French consulate and they'll give him loads of money. But anyway, you know, she gives him the money. And the other thing that's weird is that he doesn't seem in a hurry to leave. So when she says, I've got you a guide to take you to the Dutch frontier, he says, I'm not really ready yet. I'd like to wait a few days longer.
我对这个故事感到有些困惑，因为基恩和大多数逃亡者不同，他问伊迪丝，我能要300法郎吗？我需要300法郎。现在，她不清楚他为什么需要这笔钱，因为如果他真是他所说的那个人，那么当他到达荷兰时，他可以去法国领事馆，他们会给他一大笔钱。但无论如何，她还是给了他钱。另一件奇怪的事情是，他似乎并不急于离开。所以当她说，我已经为你找好向导带你去荷兰边境时，他说，我还没准备好。我想再等几天。
And he's kind of watching her the whole time, as though he's, He's observing everything. Anyway, after about two weeks, he says, OK, I'm ready to go now. The truth is, of course, he's learned everything he needs. And he is a spy. He is, in fact, not a French officer. He was a convicted criminal who was in prison
他一直盯着她看，好像在观察一切。总之，大约两周后，他说，好了，我现在准备走了。当然，事实是他已经了解了他需要的一切。他是个间谍。事实上，他根本不是什么法国军官。他是一个在监狱里服刑的罪犯，
when the Germans captured his hometown, Saint-Contin. He was short of money, and he basically offered his services to the Germans as an informant. And in this hometown, he befriended a girl called Jean Baligant, and she was connected to the Kuan network. and he sold her this story, Jeanne, about being a French officer and she fell for it. Incredibly, she took him to the castle of the Prince and Princess, and they gave him false papers, and then he was passed on to a school teacher, and then she took him to Brussels, and she took him to Edith's clinic.
当德国人占领他的家乡圣康坦时，他就在那里。他缺钱，基本上是主动向德国人提出做线人。在老家，他结识了一个叫让娜·巴利冈的女孩，她与基恩网络有联系。他向让娜编造了自己是法国军官的故事，而她信以为真。令人难以置信的是，她把他带到了亲王和公主的城堡，他们给了他假证件，然后他被转交给了一位学校老师，最后她把他带到了布鲁塞尔，带到了伊迪丝的诊所。
So Edith has now fallen for his story as well. She helps him to get to Holland. He goes to Holland. He goes to the French consulate. They give him yet more money. He's rolling, and he's got another 500 francs. But once he's got this money, he goes straight back across the border all the way back to Brussels to report to his German handlers. And so two days later, on the 31st of July 1915, the Germans spring into action.
所以伊迪丝现在也相信了他的故事。她帮他去了荷兰。他去了荷兰，去了法国领事馆。他们又给了他更多的钱。他现在很有钱，又拿到了500法郎。但一旦拿到钱，他立刻穿过边境回到布鲁塞尔，向他的德国联络人报告。于是两天后，即1915年7月31日，德国人采取了行动。
First, they raid the house of this architect bloke who runs the network, Philippe Boug. And they arrest him and they arrest this school teacher who'd been helping him, who was called Louise Tullier. And when they search Bogue's house, they find a list of names. And one of the names is Edith Cavill. On the 4th of August, the Germans raid the nursing school. And Edith is very calm. She's hidden her journal inside a cushion, and she's destroyed any incriminating papers,
首先，他们突袭了经营该网络的建筑师菲利普·博格的家。他们逮捕了他，还逮捕了曾帮助过他的学校老师路易丝·图利耶。当他们搜查博格的家时，发现了一份名单。其中一个名字就是伊迪丝·卡维尔。8月4日，德国人突袭了护理学校。伊迪丝非常冷静。她把日记藏在垫子里，并销毁了所有罪证文件，
and she and Miss Wilkins managed to keep the Germans talking, while the British soldier they've gone in the clinic escapes out through the garden. The Germans go away, but the next day, the 5th of August, the Germans come back. And this time, they come into the clinic, they look around, but when they leave, they take Edith with them. Not Miss Wilkins. Not Miss Wilkins. Edith is under arrest. She is charged with war treason, and war treason is a crime punishable by death.
她和威尔金斯小姐设法拖住德国人，而他们藏在诊所里的英国士兵则从花园逃走了。德国人离开了，但第二天，即8月5日，他们又回来了。这一次，他们进入诊所，四处搜查，但离开时带走了伊迪丝。不是威尔金斯小姐。不是威尔金斯小姐。伊迪丝被捕了。她被控犯有战争叛国罪，而战争叛国罪是可判处死刑的罪行。
Oh my goodness. Well, let's find out what happens after the break. Hello, it's Marina Hyde from The Resters Entertainment. Now, Tom, it's fair to say there isn't normally a huge amount of crossover between our podcasts. Well, Marina, I know that we have both on our respective podcasts discussed Bin Diesel's ambition to play Hannibal. I've always thought that perhaps there is potential here for the rest of history and the rest of entertainment to combine and produce something beautiful. Yes, in a crossover, nobody saw coming. The worlds of reality TV and historical high society collide live on the South Bank centre stage. Yeah, the real housewives of Regency England will see us cast a TV reality show eye onto the women of the early 19th century. And when we say the women of the early 19th century,
天哪。好吧，让我们在休息后看看发生了什么。你好，我是来自《娱乐余波》的玛丽娜·海德。汤姆，公平地说，我们的播客之间通常没有太多的交集。嗯，玛丽娜，我知道我们都在各自的播客中讨论过范·迪塞尔想扮演汉尼拔的野心。我一直认为，或许《历史余波》和《娱乐余波》有潜力结合起来，创造出一些美好的东西。是的，在一个没人预料到的跨界合作中。真人秀世界和历史上的上流社会在南岸中心舞台上碰撞。是的，《摄政时期英国的真实主妇》将让我们用电视真人秀的眼光审视19世纪初的女性。当我们说19世纪初的女性时，
we are talking about some of the most extraordinary, most charismatic, most scandalous women in the whole of British history. Exactly. Think Lady Hamilton, Jane Austen and my chaotic queen, Caroline Lamb. Yeah, so Marina and I are planning to pull out all the stops for a reality TV tour of Regency London, complete with superb dramatic recreations and unbelievable. believably exciting, a special celebrity guest from the world of the real, real housewives. The Restis Fest is running from the 4th to 6th of September at London's South Bank Centre. Members of The Rest is History and The Rest is Entertainment can get tickets on the 28th of May. General Sale goes live on the 2nd of June at 10am, visit southbankcenter.com.ukuk to find out more.
我们谈论的是整个英国历史上最非凡、最有魅力、最令人震惊的女性。没错。想想汉密尔顿夫人、简·奥斯汀和我那混乱的女王卡罗琳·兰姆。是的，所以玛丽娜和我计划为摄政时期的伦敦真人秀之旅全力以赴，包括精彩的戏剧重现和令人难以置信的、来自真实《真实主妇》世界的特别名人嘉宾。《历史余波》节将于9月4日至6日在伦敦南岸中心举行。《历史余波》和《娱乐余波》的会员可以在5月28日购票。公开发售将于6月2日早上10点开始，访问southbankcenter.com.uk了解更多信息。
Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers. The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. We often think of beating cancer as treatment, but imagine stopping it before it begins. After years of work, Cancer Research UK scientists are launching a clinical trial of lung Vax, the first vaccine designed to prevent lung cancer. It builds on TracerX, the world's largest cancer evolution study, which tracked lung cancer cells over many years to uncover the disease's earliest warning signs. Lung Vax is designed to train the immune system to spot these signs early on, destroying 40 cells before cancer develops.
嘿，这是来自Gollhangers的迈克尔和汉娜。《科学余波》。本期节目由英国癌症研究中心赞助。我们通常认为战胜癌症就是治疗，但想象一下在它开始之前就阻止它。经过多年的工作，英国癌症研究中心的科学家们正在启动肺疫苗的临床试验，这是第一种旨在预防肺癌的疫苗。它建立在TracerX的基础上，这是世界上最大的癌症进化研究，它追踪肺癌细胞多年，以揭示该疾病最早的预警信号。肺疫苗旨在训练免疫系统尽早发现这些信号，在癌症发展之前摧毁40个细胞。
So it's not treatment, but preventative, with the potential to stop lung cancer before it starts. The first stage of the trial starts this year, focusing on people at higher risk. It shows what long-term research makes possible. For more information about cancer research UK, their research breakthroughs and how you can support them, visit cancerresearchuk.org forward slash the rest is science. I saw my friend on the other side of the street. I was heading to school with the kids. I let go of mom's hand to wave.
所以这不是治疗，而是预防，有可能在肺癌开始之前就阻止它。试验的第一阶段将于今年开始，重点关注高风险人群。这展示了长期研究的可能性。有关英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究突破以及如何支持他们的更多信息，请访问cancerresearchuk.org/the-rest-is-science。我在街对面看到了我的朋友。我正带着孩子们去学校。我松开妈妈的手去挥手。
I had already forgotten their lunches. I ran over to hug her. She came out of nowhere. And then it stopped. Sometimes the moments that never happen matter most. Volvo's automatic emergency breaking helps ensure a safe ending for everyone. Learn more at Volvocars.ca.ca.com slash safety. Hello and welcome back to the rest is history. It is August 1915 and the Germans have finally
我已经忘了他们的午餐。我跑过去拥抱她。她突然出现。然后一切都停止了。有时，那些从未发生的时刻最重要。沃尔沃的自动紧急制动系统有助于确保每个人都有一个安全的结局。在Volvocars.ca.com/safety了解更多信息。你好，欢迎回到《历史余波》。现在是1915年8月，德国人终于
moved against the network of the Prince and Princess de Croix, these very posh belgians, although Dominic is, you're anxious to make clear that they're not uber posh. They're quite posh. I mean, pretty much. Yeah, posh enough. So the prince himself, he escapes to Holland, doesn't he? But his sister, the princess de Croix, and some of the other key figures in their network, they get rounded up. And among them, as you described, just before the break, is our heroine Edith. Yes. And so she is taken to the prison at St. Gilles, and she's held in this prison for the next 10 weeks. And for much of that time, she's in solitary confinement. And she's interrogated three times on the 8th, 18th, and 22nd of August and she gives statements to the Germans.
对德克鲁瓦亲王和公主的网络采取了行动，这些非常时髦的比利时人，尽管多米尼克，你急于澄清他们不是超级时髦。他们相当时髦。我的意思是，差不多吧。是的，足够时髦了。所以亲王本人逃到了荷兰，对吧？但他的妹妹德克鲁瓦公主和他们网络中的其他一些关键人物被围捕了。正如你在休息前所描述的那样，其中就有我们的女主角伊迪丝。是的。所以她被带到了圣吉尔监狱，并在接下来的10周里被关押在那里。在那段时间里，她大部分时间都被单独监禁。她被审讯了三次，分别在8月8日、18日和22日，她向德国人提供了陈述。
And there's a slight complexity here. Edith was interrogated in French, which she was very good at, remember, because she'd done 10 minutes a day at school in Peterborough. But her answers were then translated into German. And there's a biography of her by Diana Suhami. And Diana Suhami says, she thinks that the answers were slightly mistranslated to make them sound more incriminating. So she thinks, though when Kavill was asked about her motivation,
这里有一个小小的复杂情况。伊迪丝是用法语接受审讯的，她法语很好，记得吗，因为她在彼得伯勒上学时每天学10分钟。但她的回答随后被翻译成德语。戴安娜·苏哈米为她写了一本传记。戴安娜·苏哈米说，她认为这些回答被稍微误译了，使它们听起来更具煽动性。所以她认为，当卡维尔被问及她的动机时，
she said that she was saving injured men from death. If I hadn't saved them, they would have been shot. But the German translation made it sound as though she was motivated by eagerness to help the allies, which is a slightly different thing, and that's a subtle difference. And that, of course, can mean, the difference between life and death. I mean, you could be motivated by both, I think, and I think she probably is. But there's an ambiguity that runs through this story. Anyway, the important thing is she doesn't make any effort to deny what she's been doing.
她说她是在从死亡中拯救受伤的人。如果我不救他们，他们就会被枪决。但德语翻译让它听起来像是她是因为渴望帮助盟军而受到激励，这是一个稍微不同的说法，这是一个微妙的区别。当然，这可能意味着生与死的区别。我的意思是，我认为你可能同时受到两者的激励，我想她可能也是。但这个故事中贯穿着一种模糊性。总之，重要的是她没有试图否认她所做的事情。
And in fact, the figures that I quoted earlier for the number of men that she helped to smuggle to safety, they come from her own testimony. She says to the Germans, I have helped almost 200 men, some of them soldiers, some of them civilians. And her biographers and people have written about this case have often wondered why she was so candid. So one explanation is obviously that she's a pious, Victorian Christian, and she can't. tell her lie. You know, it's not in her repertoire to be dishonest. There's also people who think she's just naive. She doesn't realize the gravity of her situation. And then there are also people who say, well, the Germans told her that the other suspects had already confessed and, you know, she was gullible and she fell for it. And so she thought, what if the others
事实上，我之前引用的她帮助走私到安全地带的人数，来自她自己的证词。她对德国人说，我帮助了近200人，其中一些是士兵，一些是平民。她的传记作者和写过这个案件的人经常想知道她为什么如此坦率。所以一个解释显然是她是一个虔诚的维多利亚时代基督徒，她不能撒谎。你知道，不诚实不在她的字典里。也有人认为她只是天真。她没有意识到自己处境的严重性。还有人说，德国人告诉她其他嫌疑人已经招供了，你知道，她很容易受骗，她上当了。所以她想，如果其他人
have confessed, I might as well confess myself. I think there is definitely an unworldliness to her. I don't think she quite realizes the severity. of the situation. Or do you think perhaps she does and she is, I mean, prepared to accept a form of martyrdom? We would need to know more about her inner life to get a sense of that.
已经招供了，我也不妨招供。我认为她身上绝对有一种不谙世事。我不认为她完全意识到了局势的严重性。或者你认为也许她意识到了，并且，我的意思是，准备接受某种形式的殉道？我们需要更多地了解她的内心生活才能感受到这一点。
I mean, that's obviously a possibility that she willingly embraces martyrdom and sacrifices herself almost deliberately. But that can only be supposition because we know so little about what's going on behind the sort of, you know, behind the slightly prim nursing facade. I mean, she's clearly an unbelievably brave woman
我的意思是，她心甘情愿地拥抱殉道并几乎故意牺牲自己，这显然是一种可能性。但这只能是推测，因为我们对她那种稍微拘谨的护士外表背后发生的事情知之甚少。我的意思是，她显然是一位令人难以置信的勇敢女性。
Yeah, and very, very serious and earnest. So she describes her time in prison, for example, as a solemn fast from earthly distractions. If you're the kind of person who says that about your time in the German prison, then you're not a very, I suspect you're not a very worldly person. Or you're a person who is steeped in the narratives of Christian martyrs, because that's exactly how they talk, you know, in the early martyrologies. Of course, and I think she is. She grew up in a vicarage.
是的，而且非常、非常严肃和真诚。例如，她将自己在监狱里的时光描述为一种远离世俗干扰的庄严斋戒。如果你是那种会这样描述自己在德国监狱时光的人，那么你不是一个，我怀疑你不是一个非常世俗的人。或者你是一个沉浸在基督教殉道者叙事中的人，因为这正是他们在早期殉道录中说话的方式，你知道。当然，我认为她是。她在牧师公馆长大。
She's a nurse. Absolutely, she's part of all that. I feel that she, you know, she is aware of the script in a situation like this. Yeah, quite possibly. Quite possibly. I still don't think this makes her a brilliant dinner party companion. You and I may differ on this. After 10 weeks in prison, she's taken out on the 2nd of October to face the charges.
她是一名护士。绝对的，她是这一切的一部分。我觉得她，你知道，她意识到在这种情况下剧本是什么。是的，很有可能。很有可能。我仍然不认为这让她成为一个出色的晚宴同伴。你和我在这点上可能有分歧。在监狱里待了10周后，她在10月2日被带出来面对指控。
Now, this is not an ordinary court. It is a court martial. And it's a court martial because she's being charged with war treason under Section 58 of the German military code. And this reads as follows that in time of war anyone who with the intention of aiding a hostile power
现在，这不是一个普通的法庭。这是一个军事法庭。这是一个军事法庭，因为她根据德国军事法典第58条被控犯有战争叛国罪。内容如下：在战争时期，任何意图援助敌对势力
or out of causing harmed German troops anyone who commits one of a series of named crimes shall be punished with death for war treason. So even if she's English? Even if she's English. The code is absolutely explicit about this that this applies to anybody
或导致德国军队受损的人，任何犯下一系列指定罪行之一的人，都将因战争叛国罪被处以死刑。所以即使她是英国人？即使她是英国人。法典对此绝对明确，即这适用于任何人
in the war zone or in the occupation zone and her specific offence is conveying troops to the enemy. Now later, you see it a lot in accounts of the trial, sort of popular accounts and things, it is described as a show trial. It absolutely was not a show trial.
在战区或占领区，她具体的罪行是向敌人输送军队。现在后来，你在审判的报道中经常看到它，那种流行的报道和类似的东西，它被描述为作秀审判。它绝对不是作秀审判。
So she has a defence lawyer. Miss Wilkins chose a lawyer for her who they knew, and the Germans said, no, that person's not right. That's just a mate of yours. So Miss Wilkins is fine. She's off the hook. Yeah, Miss Wilkins is fine. But the Germans found a replacement
所以她有一名辩护律师。威尔金斯小姐为她选择了一名他们认识的律师，但德国人说，不，那个人不合适。那只是你的一个伙伴。所以威尔金斯小姐没事。她脱身了。是的，威尔金斯小姐没事。但德国人找到了一个替代者
who was a Brussels lawyer called Sadie Kirshan. And there's no suggestion that this defense lawyer let her down or, you know, was inadequate or anything like this. Well, it's tricky, isn't it? Because she's confessed everything. She doesn't deny the charges. So this is a report by a Belgian official. In her oral statement before the court,
他是布鲁塞尔的一名律师，名叫萨迪·基尔尚。没有任何迹象表明这位辩护律师让她失望，或者，你知道，是不称职的，或者类似的事情。嗯，这很棘手，不是吗？因为她已经招供了一切。她没有否认指控。所以这是一份比利时官员的报告。在法庭上的口头陈述中，
Ms. Cavill disclosed almost all the facts of the whole prosecution. She was questioned in German, an interpreter translating all the questions in French, with which language Ms. Cavill was well acquainted. She spoke without trembling and showed a clear mind. Often she added some greater precision to her previous depositions. When she was asked why she helped these socials, soldiers to go to England. She replied that she thought that if she had not done so, they would
卡维尔女士披露了整个起诉书的几乎所有事实。她用德语接受讯问，一名翻译将所有问题翻译成法语，卡维尔女士对这种语言非常熟悉。她说话时没有颤抖，表现出清晰的头脑。她经常对之前的证词增加一些更精确的内容。当被问及为什么她帮助这些士兵去英国时。她回答说，她认为如果她不这样做，他们就会
have been shot by the Germans, and that therefore she thought she only did her duty to her country in saving their lives. But I think it's here that the issue of the translation is so damaging, because the Germans say, well, hold on, are you doing this to save their lives, or are you doing this to do your duty to your country? Those are two slightly different things. Are you helping your country, or is this just about pure humanitarianism? Right, because she's saving Belgians as well, isn't she, and getting them out to go and join the Allies. Yes. So the military prosecutor said, but you haven't just helped injured soldiers.
被德国人枪决，因此她认为她在拯救他们的生命方面只是尽了对国家的职责。但我认为正是翻译的问题在这里造成了如此大的破坏，因为德国人说，好吧，等等，你是为了拯救他们的生命而这样做，还是为了尽你对国家的职责而这样做？这是两个稍微不同的事情。你是在帮助你的国家，还是这只是纯粹的人道主义？对，因为她也在拯救比利时人，不是吗，并让他们出去加入盟军。是的。所以军事检察官说，但你不仅帮助了受伤的士兵。
You have also helped young Belgians who are not in danger at all, but wanted to get out of the country to join the Allied armies. You're not saving their lives. You're actually, you know, aiding and abetting them to take up arms against us, against the Germans. And because of that point, it's very hard for them, actually, to pardon her. I know this sounds like
你还帮助了根本没有危险但想离开国家加入盟军的年轻比利时人。你不是在拯救他们的生命。你实际上是在，你知道，教唆他们拿起武器反对我们，反对德国人。正因为这一点，他们实际上很难赦免她。我知道这听起来像
I'm massively teamed Teuton. Again. The German military code, Tom, is very clear. I don't know how familiar you are with that. They're only obeying orders. Well, the penalty for her crime, right, in the code is death.
我是一个彻头彻尾的条顿人。再说一次。汤姆，德国军事法典非常明确。我不知道你对它有多熟悉。他们只是在服从命令。嗯，法典中她罪行的惩罚，对吧，是死刑。
And section, you asked about her being foreign. I don't know how familiar you are with section 160 of the German military code, but this explicitly says that in time of war, the penalties will apply to foreigners as well as to German military. and nationals. Now, you might not want to take this unwelcome news from me, but surely you would
关于她是外国人的问题，你问到了。我不知道你对德国军事法典第160条有多熟悉，但这明确规定，在战争时期，惩罚将适用于外国人以及德国军队和国民。现在，你可能不想从我这里听到这个不受欢迎的消息，但你肯定会
take it from Sir Horace Rowland of the Foreign Office, because Sir Horace Rowland, as we know now from the classified files, wrote about this day's colleagues and said, she's in a mess and was nothing we can do to save her. I am afraid it is likely to go hard with Ms. Cavill. I'm afraid we are powerless. Now, he's right, because, you know, given the legal framework, conviction is a foregone conclusion and a couple of days later on the afternoon of Monday the 11th of October the sentences are handed down so nine people are found guilty four of them are sentenced to hard labor five of them as condemned to death and the people who are condemned to death are edith cavil this bloke balk the architect the school teacher tullier who was helping him and two other people
从外交部的霍勒斯·罗兰爵士那里听到，因为正如我们现在从机密文件中所知，霍勒斯·罗兰爵士写信给同事说，她陷入了困境，我们无能为力救她。恐怕卡维尔女士的情况不妙。恐怕我们无能为力。现在，他是对的，因为，你知道，鉴于法律框架，定罪是必然的结果，几天后，即10月11日星期一下午，判决下达了，所以九人被判有罪，四人被判处苦役，五人被判处死刑，被判处死刑的人是伊迪丝·卡维尔、那个叫博克的建筑师、帮助他的学校老师图利耶和其他两个人。
i mean the princess gets off doesn't she she gets off exactly and she then pops up in the second world war doing exactly the same thing she's a very impressive woman. You can't get enough for it. Tullier, the school teacher and two of the others are given reprieves, but Philippe Bocke and Edith Cavill are seen as the worst offenders. Edith, because she has confessed and made such a sort of, she's made no secret about what she's done. And she's unrepentant. And she's unrepentant. And as a result of this, she is sentenced to death by firing squad. And the German military commander in Brussels, who has the excellent name, General Traugott von Saubitzweig, he says, I want the sentence carried out straight away, because otherwise there's going to be a
我的意思是公主脱身了，不是吗？她脱身了，没错，然后她在第二次世界大战中又出现了，做了完全一样的事情，她是一位非常令人印象深刻的女性。你无法阻止她。图利耶、学校老师和其他两人获得了缓刑，但菲利普·博克和伊迪丝·卡维尔被视为最严重的罪犯。伊迪丝是因为她已经招供，并且做出了这样的，她对自己所做的事情毫不隐瞒。而且她毫无悔意。而且她毫无悔意。因此，她被判处行刑队枪决。布鲁塞尔的德国军事指挥官，他有一个极好的名字，特劳戈特·冯·绍比茨韦格将军，他说，我希望判决立即执行，否则会有
massive hullabaloo. Like, come on, we're not going to have a massive faff and a back and forth about this. Let's just get this done. So that very night, 11 October, the German Lutheran chaplain of the prison, who's called Paul Lassur, who you quoted at the beginning, he comes to see Edith, and he says to her, you're going to be shot at dawn. And he describes it. For one moment her cheeks were flushed and a moist film passed over her eyes, but only for a few seconds.
巨大的骚动。拜托，我们不会为了这个进行大规模的折腾和来回争论。让我们把它做完。所以就在那天晚上，10月11日，监狱的德国路德教牧师，名叫保罗·勒叙，也就是你在开头引用的那个人，他来看伊迪丝，他对她说，你将在黎明时被枪决。他描述了这一点。有一瞬间她的脸颊泛红，一层湿润的薄膜掠过她的眼睛，但只持续了几秒钟。
I offered her my services as a pastor, and I stated that I was at her disposal at any hour of the day and night, but she declined it politely, but definitely. And then this bloke, Le Sur, says to her, can I not offer you some kindness? Please do not see me now the German, but only the servant of our Lord and Savior
我向她提供了作为牧师的服务，并声明我随时听候她的差遣，但她礼貌但坚定地拒绝了。然后这个叫勒叙的家伙对她说，我不能为你提供一些善意吗？请不要现在把我视为德国人，而只是我们主和救世主的仆人
who places himself entirely at your disposal. And she says, well, okay, fine. Could you get word of what's happened to my mother? My mother is 80 and she's back in Norwich. And I don't want my mum to hear about this in the newspapers. And he says, I will. And actually he says in his account, I kept my promise. I don't know how they, they must have sent a message somehow to the British.
他完全听候你的差遣。她说，好吧，好吧。你能传达一下我母亲的情况吗？我母亲80岁了，她在诺里奇。我不希望我妈妈在报纸上听到这个消息。他说，我会的。事实上，他在他的叙述中说，我信守了诺言。我不知道他们是怎么做到的，他们一定以某种方式给英国人发了消息。
Telegram or something. Yeah, exactly. And then he makes a pretty big offer to her, I think. He says, I know that you're, you know, very pious and you're a big Christian. And I know you'll want to take communion before you die. But I know you also will find it difficult. If it's coming from, and this is from his account, a German in the uniform which she doubtless hated.
电报之类的。是的，没错。然后他向她提出了一个我认为相当大的提议。他说，我知道你，你知道，非常虔诚，你是一个伟大的基督徒。我知道你死前会想领圣餐。但我知道你也会觉得困难。如果它来自，这是来自他的叙述，一个穿着她无疑憎恨的制服的德国人。
And he says, I know the Anglican chaplain in Brussels, who you also know, who's a guy called Reverend Sterling Gahan, and I'll bring him to your cell. And he says, her eyes lighted up and with great joy she accepted. I mean, I've got to say everyone is behaving very well. Exactly. And this bloke, the Reverend Sterling Gahan, He arrives later that evening.
他说，我认识布鲁塞尔的英国国教牧师，你也认识，他叫斯特林·加汉牧师，我会带他到你的牢房。他说，她的眼睛亮了起来，非常高兴地接受了。我的意思是，我不得不说每个人表现得都很好。没错。而这个叫斯特林·加汉的牧师，他那天晚上晚些时候到达。
He already knew her. The German authorities said, fine, you know, you can come. He finds this very, very emotional. To my astonishment and relief, I found my friend perfectly calm and resigned. But this could not lessen the tenderness and intensity of Phileon either part. And she says to this bloke, please tell all my friends that I willingly gave my life for my country. I have seen death so often it's not strange or fearful to me.
他已经认识她了。德国当局说，好吧，你知道，你可以来。他觉得这非常、非常感人。令我惊讶和宽慰的是，我发现我的朋友非常冷静和顺从。但这并不能减少伊迪丝那边的温柔和强度。她对这个家伙说，请告诉所有的朋友，我心甘情愿地为我的国家献出了生命。我见过死亡这么多次，它对我来说并不陌生或可怕。
And then some very famous lines, which end up being on their statue. They have all been very kind to me here, but this I would say, standing as I do in view of God and eternity, I realize that patriotism is not enough. I must have no hatred or bitterness towards anyone. And then they pray, they take communion together. And they talk quietly until the guards tell him, it's time to go. He says later, I said goodbye, and she smiled and said, we shall meet again. And then when he's gone, she writes a farewell letter to her nurses, very moving letter, actually. When better days come, our work will again grow and resume all its power for doing good. I told you that devotion would bring you true happiness and that the thought that before God you've done your duty well and with a good heart will sustain you in the hard moments of life and in the face of death. I may have been strict, but I have loved you more than you can know. Oh, very sad. Now overnight, while she's doing all this, there is a chance of a lifeline. And this comes from the Americans. People who listened to the last episode will
然后是一些非常著名的台词，最终出现在他们的雕像上。他们在这里对我都很友善，但我必须说，站在上帝和永恒的面前，我意识到爱国主义是不够的。我必须对任何人没有仇恨或苦涩。然后他们祈祷，他们一起领圣餐。他们安静地交谈，直到守卫告诉他，该走了。他后来写道，我说了再见，她微笑着说，我们会再见面的。然后当他离开后，她给她的护士们写了一封告别信，实际上是一封非常感人的信。当更好的日子到来时，我们的工作将再次增长，并恢复其行善的所有力量。我告诉过你们，奉献会给你们带来真正的幸福，想到在上帝面前你们已经很好地尽了职责，并且怀着一颗善良的心，这将支持你们度过人生的艰难时刻，面对死亡。我可能很严格，但我爱你们胜过你们所能知道的。哦，非常悲伤。现在过夜的时候，当她做这一切时，有一个生命线的机会。这来自美国人。听过上一集的人会
recall that despite the sinking of the Lusitania, the Americans have still not entered the war, and the Germans are keen not to antagonize them. And the US ambassador in Brussels, of course he has a US ambassador's name. He is called Brand Whitlock. And Brand Whitlock sends the German Governor General a note asking him for mercy. And he says her career, Ms. Cavill's career as a servant of humanity is such as to inspire the greatest sympathy. and to call for pardon. And Brand Whitlock, he's actually ill that evening. He can't be bothered to go himself.
记得尽管卢西塔尼亚号沉没，美国人仍然没有参战，德国人也不想激怒他们。布鲁塞尔的美国大使，当然他有一个美国大使的名字。他叫布兰德·惠特洛克。布兰德·惠特洛克给德国总督发了一张便条，请求他宽大处理。他说她的职业，卡维尔女士作为人类仆人的职业，足以激发最大的同情心，并呼吁赦免。布兰德·惠特洛克，他那天晚上实际上病了。他自己没法去。
So he sends a delegation from the US embassy and indeed some Spaniards, who are also neutral. And they go to see the governor. And at the head of this is a diplomat called Hugh Gibson, American diplomat. And he says, we reminded him of the burning of Louvre and of the sinking of the Lucitania.
所以他派了一个来自美国大使馆的代表团，实际上还有一些西班牙人，他们也是中立的。他们去见总督。带头的是一位名叫休·吉布森的美国外交官。他说，我们提醒他卢浮宫的焚烧和卢西塔尼亚号的沉没。
And we told him, this is the German governor, that this murder would rank with those two affairs and would stir all civilized countries with horror and discerting. And one day a podcast series will do them in succession. Exactly as we did. And at that, one of the German officials, he's called Count Harach interrupts. And he says, hold on, hold on.
我们告诉他，这是德国总督，这起谋杀案将与那两起事件并列，并将以恐惧和不安激起所有文明国家的愤怒。有一天，一个播客系列会连续报道它们。正如我们所做的那样。这时，其中一位德国官员，他叫哈拉赫伯爵，打断了。他说，等等，等等。
I would rather see Miss Cavill shot than see any harm come to the humblest German soldier. My only regret is that we don't have three or four more old English women to shoot. Well, they've got Miss Wilkins. Yeah, they could shoot. Why aren't they shooting Miss Wilkins? Yeah, she's the one that got away, no? She is. The Americans were really shocked by this.
我宁愿看到卡维尔小姐被枪决，也不愿看到任何德国士兵受到伤害。我唯一的遗憾是我们没有再多三四个老英国女人可以枪决。好吧，他们有威尔金斯小姐。是的，他们可以枪决。为什么他们不枪决威尔金斯小姐？是的，她是那个逃脱的人，不是吗？她是。美国人对此感到非常震惊。
So this book, Gibson went back and raised it down and said, which is terrible form from the Germans. Is it a joke? I think it's obviously a joke. It's German banter. Very Farnarian quip. It's Farnarian banter. Plus, the Germans have been woken up at like one in the morning
所以这个叫吉布森的家伙回去写了下来，说，这对德国人来说是可怕的形式。这是一个笑话吗？我认为这显然是一个笑话。这是德国式的玩笑。非常法纳式的俏皮话。这是法纳式的玩笑。另外，德国人被凌晨一点左右叫醒了
by this group of people who aren't even in the war. I think this bloke's just like, come on, leave us alone. We're just, you know, we're not following orders. they're just following the German military code. Yeah, I'm glad that's very clear. Yeah. So now we come to the early hours at the 12th of October. And there are different accounts to what happened,
被这群甚至不在战争中的人。我想这家伙只是想，拜托，别管我们。我们只是，你知道，我们没有服从命令。他们只是在服从德国军事法典。是的，我很高兴这非常清楚。是的。所以现在我们来到10月12日的凌晨。关于发生了什么有不同的说法，
but the most reliable is from that Lutheran pastor, Paul the Sir. It's very evocative. And that scene that you described, so he goes to the prison. She's been kneeling at her table, he's told. She's been kneeling in prayer. And he goes into the cell. And she's packed up all her stuff.
但最可靠的是来自那位路德教牧师保罗·勒叙。这非常令人回味。和你描述的那个场景一样，所以他去了监狱。据说她一直跪在桌子旁。她一直在祈祷。他走进牢房。她已经收拾好了所有的东西。
And there's just a little sort of flame burning gas flame. And she's got ready. The two of them go out of the cell, and they walk through the silent corridors of the prison, the scene that you described at the beginning. The Belgian prison guards have all lined up to sort of wish her well. And as Le Ser says, they greeted her silently with the highest respect. They get into a car, and then the Catholic chaplain comes out to the prison with Philippe Boug.
只有一个小小的火焰在燃烧，煤气火焰。她已经准备好了。他们两人走出牢房，走过监狱寂静的走廊，就是你在开头描述的那个场景。比利时监狱守卫都排成一排祝她好运。正如勒叙所说，他们默默地以最高的敬意向她致意。他们上了一辆车，然后天主教牧师和菲利普·博克一起走出监狱。
He gets into a car. He also behaves spendedly. Philippe Bogue, he says to all the German sentience in Dutch, He says, let us bear no grudge. And then he gets into the car and they drive off. And they drive to the Tien Nacional, which is the national shooting range, which is where the Germans usually hold their executions. And there, a company of 250 German soldiers is lined up, waiting for them.
他上了一辆车。他也表现得非常出色。菲利普·博克，他对所有的德国哨兵用荷兰语说，他说，让我们不要怀恨在心。然后他上了车，他们开车走了。他们开车前往国家射击场，这是德国人通常举行处决的地方。在那里，一个由250名德国士兵组成的连队排成一排，等待着他们。
They present arms. Edith and this architect Bulk are led to the front. And the sentences are read out in French and German. Bulk cries out at this point. He says, comrades in the presence of death, we are all comrades. And then someone says, pipe down, you know, stop talking. Le Sur, the Lutheran, is allowed a last word with Edith. And he so presses her hand.
他们敬礼。伊迪丝和这个建筑师博克被带到前面。判决书用法语和德语宣读。博克此时大喊。他说，同志们，在死亡面前，我们都是同志。然后有人说，闭嘴，你知道，别说话了。勒叙，那个路德教徒，被允许与伊迪丝进行最后的交谈。他握住她的手。
And he says to her in English, The grace of our Lord Jesus Christ and the love of God and the communion of the Holy Ghost be with you forever. Amen. And she says, ask Mr. Gahan to tell my loved ones later that my soul, as I believe, is safe. And that I'm glad to die for my country. And then she's led to the pole.
他用英语对她说，愿我们主耶稣基督的恩典，上帝的爱，以及圣灵的交通永远与你同在。阿门。她说，请让加汉先生以后告诉我的亲人，我的灵魂，我相信，是安全的。我很高兴为我的国家而死。然后她被带到柱子前。
She's loosely tied to this pole, a bandage is put over her eyes which the sir says as the soldier who put it on told me were full of tears and then a few seconds passed which appeared to me like eternity immediately the sharp commands were given
她被松散地绑在这根柱子上，眼睛上蒙上了绷带，勒叙说，正如那个给她蒙上绷带的士兵告诉我的那样，她的眼睛里充满了泪水，然后几秒钟过去了，这对我来说就像永恒，立即发出了尖锐的命令
two salvos crashed at the same time each of eight men at a distance of six paces and the two condemned persons sank to the ground without a sound now that makes it sound as that it's all very clean and very clinical but actually that's not the case Lassar goes on to say My eyes were fixed exclusively on Miss Cavill
两轮齐射同时响起，每轮八人，距离六步，两名被判刑的人无声地倒在地上。现在这听起来好像一切都非常干净和临床，但实际上并非如此，勒叙继续说，我的眼睛完全盯着卡维尔小姐
And what they now saw was terrible With a face streaming with blood One shot had gone through her forehead Miss Cavill had sunk down forwards But three times she raised herself up Without a sound with a hands stretched upwards And he runs forward with the doctor And the doctor says to him
他们现在看到的是可怕的。脸上流着血。一颗子弹穿过了她的前额。卡维尔小姐向前倒下。但她三次站起来。没有声音，双手向上伸展。他跑向医生。医生对他说
Don't worry These are just the sort of last automatic reflexes Before death And then she does die And Lassir said the bullet holes as large as a fist in the back, proved without any doubt that she was killed immediately. I only mention this fact because untrue rumours have been connected with it.
别担心，这只是死亡前的那种最后的自动反射。然后她确实死了。勒叙说，背部拳头大小的弹孔毫无疑问地证明她是立即被杀的。我提到这个事实只是因为不真实的谣言与它有关。
We will come back to these rumours, so keep these rumours in your heads. Then a few minutes later, he says the coffins were lowered into the graves, and I prayed over Edith Cavill's grave, and I invoked the Lord's blessing over her poor corpse. Then I went home, almost sick in my soul. So this is just one death, or two deaths, if you include, the architect against the backdrop of a war in which thousands of people are dying every month in the western and eastern fronts but it becomes a massive story on both sides of the atlantic
我们会回到这些谣言，所以把这些谣言记在心里。然后几分钟后，他说棺材被放进坟墓里，我在伊迪丝·卡维尔的坟墓上祈祷，我为她可怜的尸体祈求上帝的祝福。然后我回家了，灵魂几乎生病了。所以这只是一个死亡，或者两个死亡，如果你算上那个建筑师，在东西线每月有成千上万的人死亡的战争背景下，但它在大西洋两岸都成为了一个巨大的故事
because edith cavil has turned immediately into a martyr into an innocent victim of german barbarism so to quote sir arthur conan doyle who is very enthusiastically pouring out propaganda for the british government at this point everybody must feel disgusted at the barbarous actions of the german soldier in murdering this great and glorious specimen of womanhood. The New York Herald. The official report received today will cause a wave of horror to sweep over the world at the thought of the possibility of a nation which will perpetrate such a terrible thing succeeding in this war and dominating Europe.
因为伊迪丝·卡维尔立即变成了一个殉道者，一个德国野蛮主义的无辜受害者。引用阿瑟·柯南·道尔爵士的话，他此时正非常热情地为英国政府散布宣传，每个人都必须对德国士兵谋杀这位伟大而光荣的女性典范的野蛮行为感到厌恶。《纽约先驱报》。今天收到的官方报告将使世界因想到一个将犯下如此可怕事情的国家在这次战争中取得成功并统治欧洲的可能性而感到恐惧。
And basically the newspaper goes on to say, you know, the thought of the Germans winning must be complete anathema to any democratic American, having read this story. And the funny thing, of course, is that no. Nobody up to this point had ever heard of either Covell. It's not like she's a celebrity or something. But in the way that works brilliantly, because it means that she's a blank slate and people can project onto her this sort of idealised portrait of a kind of Christian womanhood.
基本上报纸继续说，你知道，想到德国人获胜，对于任何民主的美国人来说，读了这个故事后，一定完全是厌恶的。当然，有趣的是，不。到目前为止，没有人听说过伊迪丝·卡维尔。她不像是一个名人什么的。但以这种方式，它运作得非常出色，因为它意味着她是一张白纸，人们可以把这种理想化的基督教女性形象投射到她身上。
She's a nurse. So her kind of white, wheat uniform and the red cross on it and perfect. Exactly. So the British War Propaganda Bureau, which was operating to spread the word in America, takes her story and it puts it alongside the Belgian atrocities and the Lusitania in the sort of chamber of horrors of German crimes and the newspapers, both in America and Britain, print ever more lurid accounts of her final moments.
她是一名护士。所以她那种白色的、小麦色的制服和上面的红十字，完美。没错。所以英国战争宣传局，它在美洲传播消息，采用了她的故事，并把它与比利时暴行和卢西塔尼亚号一起放在德国罪行的恐怖室里，美国和英国的报纸都刊登了关于她最后时刻越来越耸人听闻的报道。
So this is what Lassir was talking about when he said about untrue rumours. So there were stories that German soldiers refused to fire on her and that the officers had to do it. Or the most common story, that she'd fainted, before the firing squad, and then an officer stood over her with his revolver pressed against her head and basically blew her brains out. I mean, this is not true, but it becomes, again, a little bit like the stories that we talked
所以这就是勒叙在谈论不真实谣言时所说的。所以有故事说德国士兵拒绝向她开枪，军官不得不这样做。或者最常见的故事，她在行刑队前晕倒了，然后一名军官用左轮手枪顶着她的头，基本上把她的脑浆打出来了。我的意思是，这不是真的，但它再次变得有点像我们上次谈论的
about last time about German school children being given the day off to celebrate the Sinkie of the Lusitania. It becomes a widely accepted urban legend. And you can find, you know, you can see them online, loads of examples of posters and postcards about the execution of Edith Cavill. They always show her in a nurse's uniform, which she would not have worn at the execution, marked with a big red cross. It does seem like the Lusitania in that you can see the military justification for it, if that is your perspective. But it just seems insane to have done it.
关于德国学童被放假庆祝卢西塔尼亚号沉没的故事。它成为了一种被广泛接受的都市传说。你可以找到，你知道，你可以在网上看到，大量的关于伊迪丝·卡维尔处决的海报和明信片。它们总是显示她穿着护士制服，她在处决时不会穿这种制服，上面印着一个大红十字。它看起来确实像卢西塔尼亚号，因为你可以看到它的军事理由，如果那是你的观点的话。但这样做似乎太疯狂了。
Of course. Insensitive. It's not just insensitive. I mean, it's worse than a crime. It's a mistake. Yeah, I think that's fair. You know, you were shooting a nurse. It's just mad.
当然。不敏感。这不仅仅是不敏感。我的意思是，这比犯罪更糟糕。这是一个错误。是的，我认为这很公平。你知道，你在枪杀一名护士。这简直是疯了。
Yeah, it is mad. I mean, one last thing about the propaganda, interestingly, the pictures always show her as young. Yeah, and she's what, 49 or something? Exactly. So they always show her as young, maidenly, beautiful, you know, and the fact that she was unknown meant to Cece to do that. But also it's feeding into all those images that we were talking about earlier
是的，这很疯狂。我的意思是，关于宣传的最后一件事，有趣的是，图片总是显示她很年轻。是的，她49岁左右？没错。所以他们总是显示她年轻、少女、美丽，你知道，而她不为人知的事实意味着可以做到这一点。但这也在喂养我们之前谈论的所有那些形象
of the kind of Simeon hum holding the kind of the maiden who has fainted and is dressed in flowing white robe. I mean, it's tapping into all of that. But just on your thing about it being mistaken, Tom, there is a counter argument to that, and this is as follows. The German position at the time is, this person is very, very clearly guilty. There's no question of that.
那种西蒙·休姆抱着那种晕倒的、穿着飘逸白袍的少女的形象。我的意思是，它正在利用所有这些。但关于它是一个错误的事情，汤姆，有一个反驳的论点，内容如下。德国当时的立场是，这个人非常、非常明显是有罪的。这一点毫无疑问。
And she confessed. And their argument is this. We have issued a lot of public proclamations telling people that to help enemy soldiers escape is a crime punishable by death. She knew this, and one of the things that actually really condemned her was in court. They said to her, did you know this? Now, if she'd been sensible, she would have said,
她认罪了。他们的论点是这样的：我们发布了许多公开声明，告诉人们帮助敌军士兵逃跑是死罪。她知道这一点，而在法庭上真正让她被定罪的事情之一是，他们问她：你知道这一点吗？如果她聪明点，她本可以说，
I didn't actually know that it was a crime punishable by death? Because some people did say that and they got off. She said, yeah, I knew that perfectly well, but I did it anyway. And at that point, they were like, oh, come on. Now, the issue about her being a woman, right, because this is the main thing, the fact that she's a woman. It's not even the fact that she's a nurse. the fact that she's a woman.
“我其实不知道这是死罪。”因为有些人确实这么说了，结果他们逃脱了惩罚。但她说：“是的，我非常清楚，但我还是做了。”在那一刻，他们觉得，哦，算了吧。现在，关于她是女性的问题，对吧，因为这是最主要的事情，她是个女性的事实。甚至不是因为她是护士，而是因为她是女性。
I think the fact that she's a nurse is massive. Of course. I know that, but the Germans debated this internally. We know that they debated this. Should we let her off because she's a woman? And their argument was, well,
我认为她是护士这一点非常重要。当然，我知道这一点，但德国人在内部对此进行了辩论。我们知道他们讨论过。我们应该因为她是女性而放过她吗？他们的论点是，嗯，
no, our legal code makes no distinction between men and women. That's not how the law works. So this is a guy, Alfred Zimmerman, not the Zimmerman from the Zimmerman Telegram, but another Zimmerman, who was the Undersecretary for Foreign Affairs,
不，我们的法律准则在男女之间没有区别。法律不是那样运作的。所以这是一个叫阿尔弗雷德·齐默尔曼的人，不是齐默尔曼电报里的那个齐默尔曼，而是另一个齐默尔曼，他是外交部副部长，
and he was briefing the press. He said, it was a pity that Miss Cavill had to be executed, but it was necessary. She was judged justly. It's undoubtedly a terrible thing that a woman has been executed. But consider what would happen to a state, particularly in war, if it left crimes aimed at the safety of its armies to go unpunished because they were committed by women. Yeah, I understand that. But I still think that you have to weigh, you know, if you're in the German high command, you have to weigh up, you know, which is the worst. And I think you could, you know, send it a prison, whatever.
他在向媒体通报情况时说，卡维尔小姐被处决很遗憾，但这是必要的。她受到了公正的审判。一名女性被处决无疑是一件可怕的事情。但考虑到如果一个国家，特别是在战争时期，因为罪行是由女性犯下的，就让针对其军队安全的罪行逍遥法外，那会发生什么。是的，我理解这一点。但我仍然认为你必须权衡，你知道，如果你在德国最高统帅部，你必须权衡，你知道，哪种情况更糟。我想你可以，你知道，把她送进监狱，什么的。
Yeah, I agree. I mean, deep down, I agree with you, of course. It's a deep error, I think. It's a political mistake rather than a moral mistake, I would say. And it kind of reinforces the possibility that she knew what she was doing and she was consciously marty herself. Yeah, quite possibly. I mean, all through the 20th century, the perception of her in Britain was as a sort of saintly martyr. But actually, in the last, I don't know, 30, 40 years, the perception has slightly begun
是的，我同意。我的意思是，在内心深处，我当然同意你的观点。我认为这是一个严重的错误。我会说这是一个政治错误，而不是道德错误。这在某种程度上加强了这种可能性，即她知道自己在做什么，并且是有意识地让自己成为烈士。是的，很有可能。我的意思是，整个20世纪，她在英国的形象一直是一位圣洁的烈士。但实际上，在过去，我不知道，30、40年里，这种看法已经稍微开始
to change. So in 2015, Stella Rimmington, who used to run MI5, did a documentary on Radio 4. looking at the, they went into the Belgian archives and it looks as though some of the fugitives that she was helping were carrying information about trench systems and munitions dumps and things like this. Whether she knew about that is unclear
改变了。所以2015年，曾经负责军情五处的斯特拉·里明顿在第四电台做了一部纪录片。他们查阅了比利时档案馆，看起来她帮助的一些逃亡者携带了关于战壕系统、弹药库之类的信息。她是否知道这一点尚不清楚，
but there was definitely an espionage dimension to the story which is still very murky but it doesn't undermine her courage or anything like that but perhaps it slightly strengthens the case that the Germans, you know, didn't have that much choice. And the other interesting thing I always think about it is that her, you know, that what's written on the statue, patriotism is not enough. This implies that she is a Christian heroine whose story kind of transcends the war
但这个故事中确实存在间谍活动的成分，这仍然非常模糊，但这并没有削弱她的勇气之类的，但也许这稍微加强了德国人，你知道，没有太多选择的说法。关于这件事，我总是想到的另一件有趣的事情是，她的，你知道，雕像上写的那句话，“爱国是不够的”。这暗示她是一位基督教女英雄，她的故事超越了战争
and the rivalry between nations. But actually her last words to Paul the Sir, I'm glad to die for my country. There's a slight tension there, I think. I don't think she would have necessarily recognized the tension herself. of course, because she would have thought that her Christian duty and her country were the same thing because, you know, God was on Britain's side. But I think there is a slight, not contradiction exactly. On the one hand, she says patriotism is not enough. But on the other hand, she's doing this for Britain. So which is it? You know, you're doing it for the world or for Britain?
以及国家之间的竞争。但实际上她对保罗·勒瑟尔说的最后一句话是：“我很高兴为我的国家而死。”我认为这里有一点紧张关系。我不认为她自己一定会意识到这种紧张关系，当然，因为她会认为她的基督教职责和她的国家是一回事，因为，你知道，上帝站在英国这一边。但我认为确实存在一点，不完全是矛盾。一方面，她说爱国是不够的。但另一方面，她是在为英国做这件事。所以到底是哪一个？你知道，你是为了世界还是为了英国？
Well, I suppose she would say, I love my country, but I have no hard feeling against the country that's going to, you know, it's like the beginning when she sees the joke. Germans, he says, oh, how sad that they're very tired, but equally they are invaders. She was a tremendous cacist, no? I mean, that would be an unsympathetic way of framing. I'm never unsympathetic. Anyway, what happened to her? So she was buried at the prison initially under a plain wooden cross, but in 1919, when the war was over, her body was brought back to Britain, a great honour.
嗯，我想她会说，我爱我的国家，但我对那个将要，你知道，这就像开头她看到那个笑话一样。德国人，他说，哦，多么悲伤，他们很累，但同样他们是入侵者。她是一个了不起的卡西斯特，不是吗？我的意思是，那是一种缺乏同情心的表达方式。我从不缺乏同情心。总之，她后来怎么样了？所以她最初被埋在监狱里，上面有一个简单的木十字架，但在1919年战争结束后，她的遗体被带回英国，给予了极大的荣誉。
And they had a memorial service at Westminster Abbey for her, attended by Queen Alexandra and lots of bigwigs. and then she was re-interred at Norwich Cathedral. And in 1920, the statue, which you can see today, went up just off Trafalgar Square, with the message, Patriotism is not enough, I must have no hatred or bitterness for anyone. Very similar message on the memorial unveiled in Melbourne, Australia, six years later. And then you have all of these hospitals and schools and streets all over the world.
他们在威斯敏斯特教堂为她举行了追悼会，亚历山德拉王后和许多大人物出席了。然后她被重新安葬在诺里奇大教堂。1920年，你今天可以看到的那座雕像在特拉法加广场附近竖立起来，上面写着：“爱国是不够的，我对任何人都不应有仇恨或怨恨。”六年后的澳大利亚墨尔本揭幕的纪念碑上也有非常相似的信息。然后你会在世界各地看到所有这些医院、学校和街道。
And actually, I think there's a case that she's more famous in Belgium and even France than in Britain. So I don't know whether you followed Tom, the competition in 2005. Les plus grand Belge, the greatest Belgians. So this was a big public vote in Belgium to decide the greatest ever Belgians in history.
而且实际上，我认为有理由说她在比利时甚至法国比在英国更出名。所以我不知道你是否关注过汤姆，2005年的比赛。“最伟大的比利时人”。所以这是比利时的一次大型公众投票，旨在选出历史上最伟大的比利时人。
Did you follow this? Who won? I think it was some form of none. Not King Leopold. Do you know, he actually did quite well. I think he... Would you be allowed to have a Burgundian painter or something?
你关注过这个吗？谁赢了？我想是某种修女。不是利奥波德国王。你知道吗，他其实表现得相当不错。我想他……你会被允许选一位勃艮第画家之类的吗？
Okay, we could forward out a massive rabbit hole here. It's bizarrely interesting. So they held different versions of the program in different languages. French and Flemish. So the bloke who won in the German speaking and Flemish speaking bits of Belgium was a guy called Father Damien, who's some form of missionary, Victorian missionary. Loads of people that I don't recognize at all. But one of them is Edith Cavill. Edith Cavill. She came 48th. That's not bad, considering she's not Belgian. I mean, she did well. She came ahead of the tennis player, Kim Kleisters. She came ahead of Brogel. Well, I mean, it's an instance of our insularity in Britain, isn't it,
好吧，我们可能会陷入一个巨大的兔子洞。这非常有趣。所以他们在不同的语言中举办了不同版本的节目。法语和弗拉芒语。所以在比利时的德语区和弗拉芒语区获胜的人是一个叫达米安神父的人，他是某种传教士，维多利亚时代的传教士。很多人我根本不认识。但其中一个是伊迪丝·卡维尔。伊迪丝·卡维尔。她排在第48位。考虑到她不是比利时人，这还不错。我的意思是，她表现得很好。她排在网球运动员金·克里斯特尔斯前面。她排在勃鲁盖尔前面。嗯，我的意思是，这是我们英国人狭隘的一个例子，不是吗，
that in the 100 Greatest Britons, we didn't have a Belgian? Urquil-Poero, no? Did we not have Urquil-Poero? No, I don't think we did. So I said that she's very famous in Belgium, and what about France? Well, she's actually incredibly famous in France, but in an indirect way. So, two months after she was shot on the 19th of December, 1915, a baby girl was born at the Opital Ternou in Paris. And this girl's father was a circus performer and her mother was a cabaret singer and kind of performer as well. And they had clearly been reading about the Edith Cavill case in the French newspapers. I mean, it was a big story in France. Because even though the name Edith was at that point pretty unknown
在“100位最伟大的英国人”中，我们没有一个比利时人？赫尔克里·波洛，没有吗？我们没有赫尔克里·波洛吗？不，我不认为我们有。所以我说她在比利时非常出名，那法国呢？嗯，她实际上在法国非常出名，但方式是间接的。所以，在她于1915年12月19日被枪决两个月后，一个女婴在巴黎的特尔诺医院出生。这个女孩的父亲是马戏团演员，母亲是歌舞表演歌手和表演者。他们显然在法国报纸上读到过伊迪丝·卡维尔的案子。我的意思是，这在法国是一个大新闻。因为即使伊迪丝这个名字在当时还很不为人知，
in France, these two people chose it for their baby. And their baby, and their baby, was Edith Giovanna Gassion, but Tom, we know her better by her stage name, Edith Piaf. Can I just mention one other instance of her celebrity in France, which I think is fascinating because it also demonstrates the consciousness that the Germans had of the damage that her story had done to Germany's reputation. And this relates to Hitler's visit to Paris in the wake of the fall of France in 1940. You know, and he's a tourist. He goes to the Eiffel Tower and Napoleon's tomb and all of that.
在法国，这两个人还是为他们的孩子选择了这个名字。而他们的孩子，他们的孩子，就是伊迪丝·乔瓦娜·加森，但汤姆，我们更熟悉她的艺名，伊迪丝·皮亚芙。我能提一下她在法国出名的另一个例子吗？我认为这很迷人，因为它也展示了德国人意识到她的故事对德国声誉造成的损害。这与希特勒在1940年法国沦陷后访问巴黎有关。你知道，他是个游客。他去了埃菲尔铁塔、拿破仑墓等等。
But he specifically orders the destruction of two monuments. And one is to a general who had fought against the Germans in the First World War by the name of Charlemagne. And he had occupied the Rhineland in 1918. And among the troops under his command had been Senegalese soldiers, so black soldiers. and the story was among Germans that he had licensed these soldiers to rape German women and had said that basically German women weren't good enough for his black soldiers. And the statue to him in Paris showed him with a kind of a guard of honor formed up of Senegalese soldiers.
但他特别下令摧毁两座纪念碑。一座是献给一位在第一次世界大战中与德国人作战的将军，名叫查理曼。他在1918年占领了莱茵兰。在他指挥的部队中包括塞内加尔士兵，也就是黑人士兵。德国人中间流传的故事是，他允许这些士兵强奸德国妇女，并说基本上德国妇女配不上他的黑人士兵。巴黎那座纪念他的雕像展示了他和一队由塞内加尔士兵组成的仪仗队。
So you could see why Hitler would want that destroyed because it's a French statue celebrating French aggression, as Hitler would see it, against Germany, you know, occupying the Rhineland. There's the sense of the injustice of Versailles that he's there as, you know, in the wake of the armistice. And also Hitler is obviously obsessed by the whole notion of miscegenation. So he, he's an obvious baddie. And so Hitler duly orders it to be destroyed and it's blown up. And the other statue that he orders destroyed is of Edith Carvon. and clearly her story is as offensive to him as the war record of this French general.
所以你可以看出为什么希特勒想摧毁它，因为这是一座法国雕像，正如希特勒所见，它庆祝法国对德国的侵略，你知道，占领莱茵兰。有一种凡尔赛不公正的感觉，他在那里，你知道，在停战之后。而且希特勒显然对种族融合的整个概念着迷。所以他，他是一个明显的坏蛋。于是希特勒适时下令将其摧毁，它被炸毁了。他下令摧毁的另一座雕像是伊迪丝·卡维尔的，显然她的故事对他来说和那位法国将军的战争记录一样令人反感。
And it's a kind of amazing demonstration of how haunted by this story in the wake of the First World War, even Nazis were. They wanted to erase all memory of it. So interesting. So interesting. Well, anyway, if you want to go and commune with her spirit, you can go to the statue in London. or indeed in Melbourne, I suppose, or go to one of the streets named after her. Or, I suppose, indirectly, you could listen to a song by Edith Piaf. But next week, we will be going east. We will be turning our attention to the Ottoman Empire, to the Straits of Constantinople,
这是一种惊人的展示，展示了在第一次世界大战后，即使是纳粹也多么被这个故事所困扰。他们想抹去关于它的所有记忆。太有趣了。太有趣了。好吧，总之，如果你想去和她的灵魂交流，你可以去伦敦的雕像，或者确实在墨尔本，我想，或者去以她名字命名的一条街道。或者，我想，间接的，你可以听一首伊迪丝·皮亚芙的歌。但下周，我们将向东走。我们将把注意力转向奥斯曼帝国，转向君士坦丁堡海峡，
and to one of the greatest military disasters of modern history. And this is a story with a really tremendous cast. So you've got Winston Churchill, you've got Clement Attlee, you've got Mustafa Kemal Ataturk, and we welcome onto the show thousands upon thousands of Oswald. Australians and New Zealanders, because great to have the Anzaks, as people no doubt said at the time, in the streets of Istanbul, because this is the story, the long-awaited story of the Allied attempt to seize Gallipoli. Thank you, Dominic. And listeners to The Rested History Club, of course, can hear both of them right now. And to hear them and to get the full range of benefits that come with this sensational offer of membership, go to the Restit History.com.
以及现代历史上最伟大的军事灾难之一。这是一个有着非常庞大阵容的故事。所以你有温斯顿·丘吉尔，你有克莱门特·艾德礼，你有穆斯塔法·凯末尔·阿塔图尔克，我们欢迎成千上万的奥斯瓦尔德加入节目。澳大利亚人和新西兰人，因为很高兴有澳新军团，正如人们当时无疑所说的那样，在伊斯坦布尔的街道上，因为这就是故事，期待已久的盟军试图占领加里波利的故事。谢谢你，多米尼克。当然，Rest is History俱乐部的听众现在就可以听到这两集。要收听它们并获得这种轰动性的会员优惠所带来的全部福利，请访问Restit History.com。
Thank you, Dominic. Ovo, everyone. See you soon. Au-voir. Hi, everybody. We are back with another absolutely colossal update about the rest is history festival. Well, it's massive. So on the 4th and 5th of July, we will be at Hampton Court Palace. We have a weekend of brilliant talks, live music, exclusive access to historic Royal Palace's collections.
谢谢你，多米尼克。再见，大家。很快再见。再见。大家好。我们带着关于“历史的其余部分”节日的另一个绝对巨大的更新回来了。嗯，它非常宏大。所以7月4日和5日，我们将来到汉普顿宫。我们有一个周末的精彩讲座、现场音乐、独家参观历史悠久的皇家宫殿收藏。
And yes, Dominic, most exciting of all, this is the thing I have been pushing for. And I'm so looking forward to it. We have medieval combat, a terrifying, brutal, yet completely thrilling sport. It is going to be an unforgettable two days. It is indeed. And at the core of the festival of these talks, we've got some more talks to add to the lineup. So I will be talking to the brilliant Tudor historian Tracy Borman about the secrets of the six wives of Henry VIII. I'll be talking to a friend of the show in Irish National Treasure, Paul Rouse, about whether there is an alternative.
是的，多米尼克，最令人兴奋的是，这是我一直推动的事情。我非常期待。我们有中世纪格斗，这是一项可怕、残酷但又完全令人兴奋的运动。这将是令人难忘的两天。确实如此。在节日的核心是这些讲座，我们还有更多的讲座要加入阵容。所以我将与杰出的都铎王朝历史学家特雷西·博曼谈论亨利八世六位妻子的秘密。我将与节目的朋友、爱尔兰国宝保罗·劳斯谈论是否有一个替代方案。
universe in which islands could have remained part of the United Kingdom. We'll be talking to Katja Hoyer about Weimar Germany and in particular the town of Weimar through history. And Professor Adam Smith will be telling the story of America through three presidents. And on top of all that, I'll be doing a special event with Ian Hizlop about the history of satire. And I will be on stage with Mary Beard and we will be talking about just how strange, just how alien, just how different to us Rome was or maybe it wasn't. I will be talking to Helen Castor about Elizabeth the first and we'll be discussing whether she truly was England's greatest ruler or maybe whether that title should still be claimed by Athelstan. I will be talking to Ali Ansari about
宇宙，其中爱尔兰可能仍然是联合王国的一部分。我们将与卡佳·霍耶谈论魏玛德国，特别是历史上的魏玛镇。亚当·史密斯教授将通过三位总统讲述美国的故事。最重要的是，我将与伊恩·希斯洛普一起举办一场关于讽刺历史的特别活动。我将与玛丽·比尔德同台，我们将讨论罗马是多么奇怪，多么陌生，多么与我们不同，或者也许并非如此。我将与海伦·卡斯托谈论伊丽莎白一世，我们将讨论她是否真的是英国最伟大的统治者，或者那个头衔是否应该仍然由埃塞尔斯坦拥有。我将与阿里·安萨里谈论
all things Persian with Dan Jackson about the pit of death. And I will be talking to who, friend of the show, Willie Dalrymple, about the links between ancient India and Greece and Rome. Absolutely incredible scenes. And of course, on both days, Tom and I will be on stage doing a show together as well. So on the first day, we'll be answering all our club members' questions. And then to close the festival, we will do a definitive ranking of the all-time top friends of the show. So lots to look forward to. And beyond that, there is so much else that will be happening.
所有波斯事物，与丹·杰克逊谈论死亡之坑。我将与节目的朋友威利·达尔林普尔谈论古代印度、希腊和罗马之间的联系。绝对令人难以置信的场景。当然，在这两天里，汤姆和我也会一起在舞台上表演。所以第一天，我们将回答所有俱乐部成员的问题。然后为了结束节日，我们将对节目有史以来最伟大的朋友进行最终排名。所以有很多值得期待的事情。除此之外，还有很多其他事情会发生。
across the weekend. So think of it as the ultimate summer history hangout. And your tickets will give you full access to explore the great Tudor Palace of Hampton Court and indeed the Royal Tennis Court. So that would be very exciting. There'll be food and drink fit for a king, which sounds very enticing. I picture the very glamorous people that are our club members and their summer garb. They're on the lawn at Hampton Court Palace. They're chatting about history and delightful surroundings, sipping on a refreshing gin and tonic. And it's probably the most civilized festival there's ever been. I mean, that's what I imagine anyway.
整个周末。所以把它想象成终极的夏季历史聚会。你的门票将让你完全进入汉普顿宫这座伟大的都铎宫殿，甚至是皇家网球场。那将非常令人兴奋。会有适合国王的食物和饮料，听起来非常诱人。我想象着我们俱乐部成员那些非常迷人的人和他们的夏装。他们在汉普顿宫的草坪上。他们在愉快的环境中聊天历史，啜饮清爽的金汤力。这可能是史上最文明的节日。我的意思是，这就是我的想象，无论如何。
Just a reminder, the tickets are exclusive to club members. And if you are not a member, now is the perfect time to join. So head over to the rest ishistory.com to sign up and grab your tickets and, of course, have access to a whole range of supplementary benefits. Once you have signed up to the rest of history.com, all you do then is log into the members area and you select festival and it's all very obvious. But you know what? There is a twist. If you do this, you will be entered into a genuinely unbelievable prize draw. And that prize draw, if you win, you and three other people, it's like the golden tickets in Charlie and the Chocolate Factory, because you will be given the chance to be upgraded to the premium. And the premium experience will give you, among other things,
提醒一下，门票仅限俱乐部会员。如果你还不是会员，现在是加入的最佳时机。所以前往therestis-history.com注册并抢购你的门票，当然，还可以获得一系列补充福利。一旦你注册了therestis-history.com，你所要做的就是登录会员区并选择节日，一切都非常明显。但你知道吗？有一个转折。如果你这样做，你将参加一个真正令人难以置信的抽奖活动。那个抽奖活动，如果你赢了，你和其他三个人，就像《查理和巧克力工厂》里的金奖券一样，因为你将有机会升级到高级版。而高级体验将为你提供，除其他事项外，
unlimited food and drink for free all day. Do not miss it. Can't wait to see you there. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
全天无限量免费餐饮。千万不要错过。迫不及待地想在那里见到你。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。